Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn. It's
the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
June 2nd,
2014 oh my God.
Is it really Jill? Yes. Yes. Uh,
Tricia fucking June comes after me
every goddamn year. That's right.
The summertime is coming. You know,
you, you, you just showed us started.
You're going on your fucking bikini
diet back in February, but you didn't,
you got all wrapped up in
your life. Didn't yell well,
it's not your fault Tricia.
What I pick Trish. I don't
know why. You know what?
Cause I'm sick of saying Karen and Cathy,
I've got to fucking make fun of some
other God damn names and I'll have the
audacity to do it.
Even with a name like bill,
a nice generic fucking name.
No imagination. You know,
actually I actually liked my name.
I don't know what happened.
Somewhere along the lines about
in the 90s you know what I mean?
Everybody started to have all
these fucking, those names.
George Carlin made fun of,
right? George Callen, you know,
Dakota and all those things,
all those names that had to sound
like a fucking canyon right now.
All those people are coming of age
and all of a sudden I saw my first,
I don't know,
I was watching some sport and they
fucking over to a fucking Dakota assumpted
and I'm like,
am I that fucking old that somebody
named Dakota is old enough to play a
professional sport? I'm sorry.
Anyways, I'm in a weird mood today.
I uh,
this podcast is actually late this week.
I'll give you two cause it's
not even Monday morning.
You probably think of why bill, you're
a fucking comedian. You're a bum.
You don't even have a real job.
How come you can't get your ass out of
bed early enough to even record it on
your Monday morning?
Well, I'll tell you why.
Last night I uh,
took the lovely Nia out to the Hollywood
bowl and we saw Bruno fuck in March
with the,
for Ralph or feral and I have
fucking says they Farell,
the guy who walked by watching his set
evidently wrote 40% of all hits in the
last 15 years. I was just standing
there as he went in from song to song,
go like Jesus Christ, this guy,
Yo, he wrote this song too.
It's just him. I thought that other guy
sang it and then my wife would be like,
no, he produced it for him
and it went all these grammys.
He's kind of awesome.
I know he kind of was, he was out there
with his big smokey, the bear hat.
This one was red. Probably a special one
because he's playing the Hollywood bowl.
That was a great thing about the show
last night and you could tell that both
him and a Bruno Mars,
we're really excited to be playing the,
uh,
the Hollywood bowl was great. They were
just phenomenal fucking performers.
And uh,
you know,
the only thing the whole night I would
say was for rouse a backup dancers.
They would dress like they
was still at rehearsal.
That's the only thing I didn't
like, you know, I'm sure I
obviously they did it on purpose,
but you ever watch one of
those movies like fame or,
uh, I dunno. Bill and Ted's big adventure.
One of those fucking movies from
back in the aids, the debt eighties.
The fuck did I say aids? the
80s, the age 80. He VH one.
Who got it? Who didn't? And who
is surprised about the results?
Um, the 80s. Um, what the fuck? You know,
there was a bunch of those,
those movies, Michael Douglas,
all of those movies when they
would be in rehearsal, right.
And there'd be all these fucking smoking
hot women dressed like they were going
to paint their bedroom. That's how, uh,
for Elza backup dancers were dressed
last night. And um, other than that,
I thought it was great.
He sang all these fucking songs.
I don't know. He sang that one with
the guys who dress up like the robots,
you know? Yeah. Well I'm
up all night to get lucky.
I'm up all night to get sub debt.
I'm up all night doing blow. Yeah,
he's about boop, boop, boop. All right.
And everybody's going nuts. And as a desk,
go ball was a great fucking time.
Great fucking time.
And I take through the
whole God damn concent.
So we're sitting there and
now I'm one of those people,
I never see a nightmare can spot
famous people all the fucking time.
I never do. So we're
sitting there, we got,
we got great seats and uh,
she hits me on the arm.
She goes, oh my God,
there's Henry Winkler and I look
over and there he is, the fonts.
Henry Winkler having a great time dance
into Farell and then in between the
break she fucking elbows me again is like,
oh there's Tom Hanks,
swear to God and there he
is standing in the aisles.
People are coming up to him and he's
grabbing their phones and doing a selfie
forum.
He looked like he was running for office.
He stood there for like a half
a fucking hour. Like you know,
my wife was go look at that. He's
like the greatest. So he's looking,
he's the greatest guy ever.
It's like gag gift.
Guess that's how you
have a 30 year career.
You have a 30 year career by doing
exactly the opposite of what I do.
I can tell you this,
after watching that man stand there
for a half an hour as gracious is,
is you could possibly be with anyone
and everyone who walked up to him. Um,
I can honestly tell you without a doubt
that Tom Hanks does not have one drop of
cont in him.
He's just a fucking great guy.
I already liked him and then I watched
that and I'm like, Jesus Christ, you know,
I need to work on myself.
Guy.
He's putting on a goddamn good shit
clinic here at the Hollywood ball.
So, uh, so now I'm like, Jesus Christ,
these all these fucking people here.
Neal's like, oh, there's
Natalie call. There's this fog.
Can I Eddie Rabinowitz? I didn't even know
half the fucking, she's pointing out. So
I start looking around and I go,
I look at that guy over there
with the Jackson Brown hair cut.
He turned around with Jackson Brown.
He was not standing in the aisles.
But does that make them a bad person?
Maybe that's the Cantinas Tom Hanks
because he does that now you're expecting
every other famous person doing. Then
when they, when they don't do it,
okay.
I bet all those famous people are just
sitting there looking at Tom Hanks,
staring daggers at him. Like, why
won't he just sit the fuck down?
He doesn't like doing that
either. They're all fucking, um,
and he's been out there for a
half a fucking hour, you know,
and then all of a sudden
they all seem approachable.
Okay.
I liked the handlers.
There was a couple of handlers when
they were down there to basically be a
security person.
Eat.
What you have to do is you have to master
the hand an inch away from the small
of somebody back. You just sort
of leave it there. You know,
I don't know when,
if they got like a fucking inner ear
piece that dense says when they actually
make contact with the lower back of the
famous person to guide them through.
But the thing is,
is when you're,
you're in the ready position
as a security person,
you have your hand in the
small, like an inch away, right?
Like you're warming your
hand on a fucking fire,
except it's some famous
person's lower back.
This guy stood there the whole fucking
time and every once in a while he just
sort of shift the person.
Okay.
It's incredible. I Dunno how it
was fucking arm didn't get tired.
Just holding it like that. You don't have
it. He has to do stretches. So anyways,
so for outcomes out, it's like
broad daylight. He's got to perform.
Then I thought he did.
You know, I don't know,
just as a comedian performing outside in
broad day light, to me that just says,
oh my God, I'm going to bomb. And uh, um,
I better get the check before I go out
on stage. That's what I see. But he was,
he was phenomenal. Um, and then,
then Bruno Mars came out and it was a,
I don't know, dude, I called it, Nia
told me that she was like, you called it,
you saw this kid like whatever,
three,
four fucking years ago you saw him on
something and you will, I did. I was like,
this guy, he's old school. He's this song
and dance man here. This is throwback.
This dude can do anything.
He's going to have a long career.
The only thing stopping him is him. And
he didn't stop himself from there. He was,
and he put on a fucking unbelievable show.
His band was awesome.
His drummer was fucking sick.
He introduced him and his as his brother,
I dunno,
I dunno if he,
if he meant that in a cool way or we
literally came from the same parents.
I have no idea. Uh, but that
guy was killer and then his
band was fucking amazing.
And uh, what I liked about it was
that they were like, they were silly.
They were having a good time
and they were killing it.
And there was moments during the show
where they were fucking around trying to
make each other laugh and shit.
And, uh, I dunno man. It was just,
it was an amazing show.
And I also, you know,
with each concert am getting older and
older and I really should have, you know,
like when you see a, uh,
a performer on stage,
okay.
You know, and they just fucking old
now and everybody says like, Oh man,
he should just stop. She should
just quit, hang it up. You know,
put a couple of shirts on. If you're
going to go out there, Jesus Christ,
at least at a fucking treadmill
or whatever they say, you know,
we should just stop. You know? I think
that that goes with audience members too,
because I got to tell you last night,
I can't even tell you how many times I
had to sit down because just literally
standing up for too long,
my lower back starts killing me.
And I remember sitting down at one point
as Bruno Mars is on the stage and he's
fucking sitting there going,
ah,
yeah,
you know, hey, the fucking left side,
the right side now down the center.
And I'm just saying, if this
guy sees me sitting down, right,
okay.
You know,
I don't want somebody on stage see me
sitting down thinking I'm sitting down,
you know, because I'm not
appreciating what they're doing.
I almost wish I had like a neon sign
that said, it's not your fault. It's me.
I'm fucking old.
And I was literally sitting there
laughing as I'm drinking a water.
Okay.
You know,
like I,
I was actually exercising rather than
just trying to stand up for longer than 12
minutes that I sat down and I really
thought about it. I was like, is it,
am I too old to go to a concert?
I, I, I think I need to retire.
Okay.
You know,
cause I'm getting to those scary years
when you're older and you go to a concert
and you just feel the need to put on a,
I'm going to a rock show tee shirt.
You know what those older white guys do?
And they'll put on one of those fucking
Justin Timberlake hats and you're
wearing a tee shirt, which, you know,
unless you kept you self and shape,
we should never be out of the house
with a fucking tee shirt on, you know,
with your fucking man
boobs. You know, look,
I'm like be cups just sitting there and
then you have some sort of bedazzled
mint on your tee shirt to let people
know that you still can rock. You know,
you show up with those
fucking genes that just say,
I saw fucking Molly Hatchett
back in [inaudible] 82 or
whatever the fucking guys
name is, right. Don't want to be that guy.
And I'm, I'm not gonna lie to you.
I saw a lot of that last night,
which is just a testament
to both of those guys,
how talented they are because it really
was everything from little kids, um,
little kids to me and like 14,
15 all the way up to like,
I don't know how old is
Henry Winkler? Like 70. Um,
okay.
But anyways, and it was funny, it
was a guy sitting in front of us,
this old dude who was well
into his sixties, I think,
and he was part of that last
of that generation. You know,
those older guys from that generation
that just always walk around with that
navy captain's hat on.
You know,
some of them was because they were
in the navy. The rest of them,
I don't know why they wear it, but
they just, maybe they have a boat.
They just walk around with
that fucking navy hat on. Um,
he was of that age and what was
killing me is I'm sitting there going,
you know what? I'm closer in age to
the fucking navy hat guy. Then, uh,
you know, the fucking twentysomethings
here, whatever. Anyways,
it was a fucking great show.
And so that's why the podcast was like,
so he probably thinking like,
wait a minute, bell, let's show.
Probably started at seven o'clock.
Meaning you probably left your
house around six game seven Chicago,
La Kings. That was at five o'clock. What'd
you watch the first period and leave?
No,
I taped the game.
Yeah,
listen to this shit. This is how great
it is to be a hockey fan out in la.
I taped game seven of the western cons
conference finals involving the Los
Angeles kings and the Black Hawks of
Chicago. I go to the Hollywood bowl.
There's like, what? I don't know how many
people is that place hold? 10 15,000.
I'll fucking know.
And I didn't have to worry about anybody.
Okay.
Shouting out, going age two to
one, two to one, five minutes in,
rolling in it for me all.
I did it with,
all I need to do is shut up my phone so
no one would send me a text. And, uh,
I went to the concert,
I came home,
I watched the first period and if by
that point I was like one in the morning
and I was fucking tired as shit.
So I went to bed and then I woke up this
morning, but we'll do a little dude.
And uh,
I just watched the rest of it
this morning and like an asshole. I
didn't add time to it. I don't know why.
Always had time. This is the one time
I did and I just hit record and I left.
So I didn't have the overtime.
It looks like he scored about six.
Alec Martinez scored
six minutes into the overtime.
Uh, my condolences to all Blackhawk
fans. Congratulations to all kings fans.
And not to use the Cliche, but I'm
going to go, I'm going to use it.
There really are no losers in a Shitty,
like of course, series a series like this.
Of course there is, um, you know,
because when you lose it sucks.
But I gotta tell you,
man,
like if the NHL ever decided to put all
seven games of that series on a DVD,
I would be one of the first
people to buy it because it was a,
it was that good top shelf level hockey
and all you fucking cunt to watch
hockey. You know, you
watch the gold medal game.
Okay?
You know, once every four years,
you watch one fucking game.
Just imagined seven of those,
that level of intensity except even more
cause it's actually for a real trophy.
Okay. Then not play it for a
fucking necklace. You know,
with some bgs Medallian hanging off of
it that play in for the fucking Stanley
Cup. That's what they all want
to win. They would never say it.
You can't say that in public.
What would you rather deal when the
gold medal game for your country?
Or would you rather win the fucking
challenge that they're going to put your
name on? It's a no brainer. F My country.
I'm going to Nashville and I'm
going to try to win the cup. Right.
Least that's what I would think. Um,
gives a fuck about winning a gold medal.
Yeah. Unless you're like you're
cross country ski with that rifle.
I mean there's no way to go pro in that
so that, that Chicago, you got to do it.
But if you're actually
professional athlete, right?
You got a Maserati sitting in
your fucking garage. You know,
you've got some hottie jumping
on your fucking Dick every night.
Do you really? EMEA got fucking
gold necklace. I go by what?
You can't buy a Stanley Cup. Oh, show.
You can make one out of cardboard and tin
foil and stand in the crowd wearing in
a jersey look like some giant
fucking make a wish kid right now.
That's not what these people play for.
This fucking series was amazing.
If you get a chance,
I don't know if nhl.com is gonna
is gonna. I mean, I don't know.
They have the highlights, but they
usually, I dunno how you do it.
I remember back in the days when I used,
when I used to live in Boston,
what was cool over the summertime was
Nesson and that's a network over the
summertime. They used to have
these, these things called, uh, uh,
some are cooler and over the summer they
would play like the best Bruins games
throughout the year.
So the Bruins would always win the game.
It'd be some dramatic victory and there'd
be like a bench clearing umbrella and
a big fight or something like that.
It was great. The summer coolest.
So I don't know if they're going
to show it, but whatever. Um,
I got to tell you this and
somewhere along the lines, you know,
I was rooting for the kings even
though I still love Chicago.
I rooted for the Kings cause
they were the underdogs. And uh,
but then I was also going man,
Chicago Rangers to original six.
I mean when's the last time they
met each other in the playoffs?
I mean the finals, I'm trying never
in my lifetime as far as I know,
seventies were a little weird.
We'll see.
The Rangers got to the
finals in [inaudible] 79 and
they played the Canadians
and I don't think they got
in the rest of the time.
76 was the fucking flyers lost.
The Canadians savvy.
Seven or 78, one of those was the
Bruins. Too many men on the ice game.
When Gila floor the fucking flower,
um,
scored on the weakest fucking
wrist shot you ever saw.
We nobody knew to go
down in the butterfly.
So to fuck we had was standing up in neck
and he did like a little fucking flail
that at with this
fucking pad. Um, anyways,
let me just continue one. Oh, by the way,
remember long time ago I gave a lot of
today's hockey players Shit because most
of them hadn't even scored 50 goals.
And then I listened to Dan practice. Uh,
I recorded it because he had Wayne
Gretzky on the great one. And uh,
I actually listen it in Gretzky
said that he would have a PR,
he would have problems scoring 50 goals,
how good and how big the players are
now and how great the defenses are.
So I will shut the fuck up
about that immediately. Um,
but anyways, yeah. So I
started rooting for the Kings.
You know, I've just liked that
team for a number of years.
I just like how they play and everything.
And I just watched a bunch of games and
I somehow became a fan and I was sitting
out there this morning watching the rest
of the game and somebody on the king's
took a shot. And I like when like, oh,
like I freaked out
cause he just missed it.
Then they scored a goal and I flipped
out and then Nia just looked at me.
Okay.
And she just went,
shame on you.
But did you abandon the Boston Bruins
and just put me in this defensive on
McKnight and abandon Moses out.
You know, I'm a fan of hockey,
I'm rooting for the king.
She goes,
how can you as a fan of Annie Boston
team route for a fucking La team?
It's like, I know, you're right. You're
right. I don't know how it happened.
You know,
I actually was a fan of the,
the Los Angeles Dodgers in the late
seventies before the Lakers Celtics thing
heated up in the 80s and that was
just because they hated the Yankees.
We can have a beat them. And there was
the Bucky Dent Games. So in 77 and 78,
the Dodgers played the fucking Yankee,
so I'm not rooting for the Yankees.
So I would really root for the Dodgers
and I became a Dodgers fan. Um,
I love Tommy Lasorda right through
when they beat the Yankees in 81,
Fernando valance Swayla when they beat
the A's, Kurt Gibson hobbling around,
fucking pumping his fist, all of that
shit. I was a Dodgers fan. And then, uh,
then I moved out here and I went
to a Dodgers game, you know,
when I saw how cunty they're fucking
fans are, they don't show up late.
They got a knife to your throat. I
mean, I'm exaggerating but not really,
kind of has like a little
sort of biker rally vibe.
Um, yeah, I told you it's just, I'm
a kings. Fans are more mellow though,
but it's just not,
it's,
I don't know what it is about from fucking
San Francisco on down out here on the
west coast.
These people take it way too seriously.
If you have the Jersey of another team,
I mean,
it's bad enough when you do that
in other parts of the country.
But this is the last fucking place I
would come wearing the Jersey of an of the
opposite team. There's no
fucking way. No fucking way.
I like where my nose is on my
face. I like my teeth. I like my,
my brain and swollen, you
know, I like not having little,
a extra breathing holes throughout
my chest. And he called me crazy,
call me a pussy. I mean, that's
just, just, just how I am.
You haven't one time from some fucking
celebrity, you know, one of those,
those Tufts celebrities,
you know,
they get movies and they played enough
tough guys that they start to think that
they know how to fight and save the
world was talking about wearing um,
another team's Jersey to a Laker game.
They like,
aren't you worried about blah blah,
blah. And he's like worried about what?
Like he says, bad ass.
It's like, fuck you.
What the court side seats,
you know,
walking in and out of the celebrity
entrance at the fuck a town car go where
that and the upper deck.
All right.
Let's see if you live long
enough to do the sequel
to a I am cunt face part too,
right? All right. Whoa. Jesus. Bill,
you're in a mood. I am. I'm a little
tired and then I ate bad already today.
Oh my God,
eight so bad.
Do you know last week I got
to mention this before I,
before I do in the advertising
was fucking hilarious.
I didn't even realize I said it. I
was talking about something. I said,
I've got him.
Such a Gemini I have never taken out of
that might've been the most shit I ever
took for anything that
I said on the podcast.
I must've got like,
I don't know,
like 30 or 40 I retweeted a couple.
They,
whoever wrote those, you guys had
me dying laughing. Just, you know,
like when you,
you say something and you don't even
realize how fucking a feminine it is until
somebody brings it up and then it's
just so bad and the jokes are so good.
You can't do anything but laugh.
I was like sitting by myself and
the first one came in and this,
I think that was the one who
retweeted somebody wrote,
you know, I really had you, I don't know,
something about the level of
respect they had for me, you know,
was that a high level?
And then it all went out the window
the second I said I'm such a Gemini.
And then I got like, and I was
just like, Oh fuck did I say that?
And I kind of started laughing.
Sarber tweeted that one and then I kind
of scrolled down and there was like 10
other ones and each one was just more
and more brutal. Um, so whatever.
That's a shout out to ever fucking wrote
those things because you guys gave me a
great left this week. So,
so why, why, why, why,
why not just continue setting
myself up to get trashed here.
Um, you know what I did this morning,
you know why the podcast is late?
Because this morning I was
making homemade cupcakes.
I swear to God,
frosting and all that shit.
That was frost and cupcakes when
I was watching the end of a game,
seven Nhl game,
the toughest man sport,
arguably out there,
I was frost and cupcakes.
You know what?
I stand by it.
I don't give a fuck how much shit you
guys give me on Twitter because I know you
got it because it's fun. But uh,
you know, what do you want for me?
It's my wife's birthday today.
One of our favorite
things in the world is a,
she likes cupcakes with
chocolate frosting,
but out here they usually
have the chocolate frosting
with the chocolate cake.
She likes the yellow cake with chocolate
frosting, myself included. All right,
insert interracial.
Couple joke there. Um, so,
and how I was, I'm sick of driving
around trying to find them at fucking,
and you know, every God damn
bakery out here. I said, fuck it.
I'll make some went out and bought
a couple of trays. You know what?
Let me tell you something about
people make cupcakes. Okay. Fuck them.
It's not that hard.
Actually took out my kitchen aid is
the second time I used it one time.
I used it for fucking Ah, look at all this
product placement, nhl.com. Kitchenaid.
I, she's got to start getting paid
for this shit. Um, so I fucking,
uh,
I took that thing out for the first
time a couple months ago and I made some
homemade pasta and a, this is the first
time I used it when I was actually bacon.
It's the shit.
It's like having an assistant that you
don't have to fucking pay ever things
over in the corner just doing the shit.
You don't want to do.
Stern it up as you're
doing some other bullshit.
And I gotta tell you
something dead delicious.
And everybody who wanted
the wants to give me shit.
I'm going to tell you right now, if
I shut one down your pie hole, you,
you'd have to say, God dammit.
Bill. It's a good cupcake.
I got to give it up to you.
I don't respect you anymore as a man.
That's a good God damn, uh, cupcakes. So,
Hey, get into the Stanley Cup finals here,
the Stanley Cup finals.
Uh,
I picked Chicago to winning it all wrong.
I crushed the first round.
You know when the number one
was playing the eighth seed,
I called those all day after
the fucking second round.
I mean into the second round after the
first round is what I'm trying to say.
I have, I've just been horrible.
Um, so if I pick your team, you,
you should be nervous.
So right now,
range of fans and kings
fan supposed to be saying,
if you believe in that Mojo fucking Voodoo
shit should be telling me to shut up.
Well, you know what, I'm not gonna. Um,
I thought the Canadians were going to
beat the ranges and I thought the, uh,
I thought Chicago was
going to beat the kinks.
Obviously neither of that happened,
but I'll tell you who picked it perfectly
was Joe Barton. Nick, Joe Barton.
Nick said Kings in seven gangs the
kings one in seven games add Joe Barton.
Nick. All right, getting off. You want to,
you're going to give a little tippy a cap.
Go to add Joe Barton.
Nick on the Twitter, on the Twitter APP
thing, whatever the fuck you call it.
And I have a listen to a Joe Barton.
Nick has his own podcast.
It's all hockey talk.
It's called puck off. Um,
and uh,
have a listen to whatever the guy,
the guy really knows his shit and
he's as big as fucking Cam Neely.
So there you go. Um, anyway, so who am
I picking in the finals? I think, uh,
I actually love both teams.
How fucked up is that?
I love in New York and an La team.
I don't love the fans,
but I loved the team and uh,
just watching both of them throughout the,
the last series, I don't know how
you can hate either one of them,
but I got to go with the experience
and I got to take the fucking La Kinks,
you know, two great
goaltenders you know what?
And I say bet the over
and all of these games,
cause everyone's gonna think
Johnathan quick and fucking, uh,
whatever the fuck his name is suit
wherein Lundquist said Henri Henrik,
whatever the fuck you call a,
they think that there's going to be low
score and I don't think it's going to be,
I think they get to run into them.
I think doesn't make a lot of
goalie masks falling off, you know,
and there's going to be some upset,
padded,
bearded gentlemen on both sides of the
ice going, what the fuck? You know? Um,
I just think it's going to be a great
series and uh, good luck to both of you.
I'm watching every second of it.
So this is your last series.
If you're gonna ever going
to watch hockey. Well,
I make you want you to get an October,
but you know, whatever. Come on man.
Jump on the fucking bandwagon.
Have a good time. All right. Um,
okay, what else? Oh, let me
do some advertising. Let me
just knock these things out.
Shall We?
Where am I?
Where the fuck is he advertising
that right? There we go.
All right, note to host,
please personalize areas highlighted
in bold. You know, I'm really getting,
isn't it, isn't it? It's hard enough
for me to read these fucking things.
All right. Dollar Shave club, everybody.
There were so many things that
piss me off. You know what?
Sticking my hand into the bowl,
like towards the end when I'm trying to
frost a cupcake and the frosting gets on
my knuckles and I have to lick it off.
Just knowing that that's extra time
I'm going to spend on the treadmill,
you know? But then I'm happy that I
am frosting a cupcake. So you know,
it's kind of happy and sad,
you know, I'm such a Gemini
and paying way too much to shave.
My face is definitely up there.
Nothing feels better than
shaving with a fresh new blade.
But new razors are so ridiculously
expensive that you can't afford to change
your blade more than
once every six months.
So you end up scraping up
your face with an old blade.
Dollar Shave club delivers top quality
raises for a few bucks a month.
Dollar Shave Club members always shave
with a fresh blade because they get a
fresh pack in the mail every month.
Talk candidly about your
experiences with the program. Well,
I lather up my face and I use that fresh
blade and when I'm done I wash it off
and my face is smooth.
Is Dr Carver's easy shave plot?
Um, yeah, they got lots of
other great products like
the one I just mentioned. Um,
and doctor calve is post shave.
Join the hundreds of thousands of guys
who've upgraded to the smarter way to
shave, shave time, shave money,
join dollar shave club.com. Join
now@dollarshaveclubdotcomslashbarsupportthispodcastandagreatcompanybytodollarshaveclub.com
slash burr one more time.
Dollar Shave club.com/burr.
That's bur also if you want
to support this podcast,
you can go to the podcast
page on billboard.com and
click on the Amazon link and
go shopping.
Won't cost you any extra money and they'll
kick me a little doe ray me there for
sending you sending traffic their
way. All right. Um, what's next?
stamps.com everyone.
Hey,
when you think about the best
time to go to the post office,
you probably guessing before work, after
work or during lunch. Wrong. That's,
that's, that's when it's the most
crowded. Well obviously nobody's at work.
Are they talking down to us@stamps.com
and I don't think I liked this. Um,
everyone's going at that time.
The truth is there's no convenient
time to go to the post office.
That's why you need stamps.com
actually in defense of them,
that's the only time you
can go if you have a job,
right with stamps.com access
all the services of the
post office right from your
own desk.
Buy and print official US postage for
any letter or package using your computer
or your printer and then just
hand it over to the mail carrier.
So easy and unlike the post office,
stamps.com is open 24 seven with no
lines so you can get your mailing and
shipping done whenever
it's convenient for you.
I use stamps.com to send out all my
posters, DVDs, whatever crap I'm selling.
At the end of my shows,
I am a moron in even.
I can figure out stamps.com so if I
can, so can you, how do we do it? Well,
first of all, special offer right
now. Use My name and my last name,
B u r r for this special offer.
No risk trial plus $110 bonus offer that
includes a digital scale and have to
$55 free postage. Don't wait. Go to
stamps.com before you do anything else,
click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburrthatstamps.com
enter
[inaudible]. All right. Oh,
I almost forgot to thank everybody who
came out to the Improv in Arlington,
Texas this week.
I had a great time performing few guys
getting ready to do my standup special
June 20th at the Tabernacle
Theater in Atlanta.
Tickets are on sale right now.
Um,
both shows looking like
they're going to sell out.
So I want to thank everybody that,
uh,
spent your hard earned cash to watch me
go dance around and tell my jokes on the
20th. I'm really looking
forward to it. And, um,
I had a great time in Dallas, as
always, big fan of Texas and um,
and most of you who listen to my
podcast know that I am a huge fan of,
uh, the discovery channel show fast
and loud, the gas monkey garage guys.
So, um, I'm like, I gotta go over
there, I gotta go check this place out.
And, um, I went over to their garage,
they got a gift shop over there with
all these tee shirts and stuff. And um,
you know, fortunately enough, the,
uh, the owner Richard was nice enough,
he was out of town. He had a few
people over there take me around.
And, um, I just, I just had
a great time. I saw the cars.
It was ridiculous. I came walking in
the back total fucking fanboy, right.
Actually nervous as I'm walking in there,
I'm such a fan of the fucking show,
right. And, uh,
I come walking in the back and then
there's like all these guys that I've seen
on the show and, um, long
story, fucking short,
long story short, I,
uh, I got to, you know,
I got to see all these cars,
some of the cars that they're working on,
upcoming episodes, I'm not going
to ruin anything that's coming up,
but they're working on some of the
coolest cars that they've had since the
beginning of the episode. And, um,
and then as I'm walking out in
the parking lot and there's a,
that army green f 100 that he has
Frankenstein or whatever they call it,
a lot of you guys who are
fans of the show, watch them,
you know, Redo that truck.
And, um, I guess since they did it,
he put an even faster engine in it. Long
story short, the guy over there, Jason,
was giving me the tour, who was really
nice to me the whole weekend. Um,
he goes, hey, you want Casey to give you
a ride in that truck? And I'm like, man,
I don't want to bug the guy. Of course
I do, but I don't want to bug the guy.
I don't to be some fucking jerk off.
I already met the guy.
He didn't know who the fuck I was. Right.
So it's not like I could be like, Hey,
I'll give you one of my fucking stupid
standup DVDs if you get, I had nothing.
I was just another jackass
walking in there. So he was
cool as hell. He goes, yeah,
I'll give you a ride. So we start
driving around the block in the truck.
He's talking to me about the
truck and all that type of shit.
And we get on this straight away. Right.
Thank God they didn't film the state.
They wanted to film it, but they didn't
have any batteries in their camera.
They will stick one on
the, uh, the windshield.
It was the fastest fucking
thing I've ever been in.
He just lets out the clutch and it just,
wow.
We start flying down the street.
I can literally feel the back end just
ever so subtly going left to right
because there's no weight
in the back. And, um,
I felt like it was in a drag racer and I
was trying so hard to not freak out and
not be a pussy, but I'm not
gonna lie to you had to put my,
I put my foot up on a fucking dashboard
cause there was no seatbelts and I'm
feeling this thing skating in the back.
So we just go down the street.
Yeah,
I fucking faces contouring
and then he slows down
and I just go,
Jesus fucking Christ.
What are you trying to give me a
heart attack? And he just, you know,
it deadpan humor just sort of laughs and
he goes, uh, yeah, that was second gear,
second gear.
We're going like 70 miles an hour down
this little ass fucking road cars parked
on both sides. Um, it took,
it literally took me about four hours
to come down from probably the three
seconds that we would drive in that
fast. But uh, I got to do that.
How cool is that and how cool are the
people at gas monkey that they actually
took time out of their day to let
me do that? I'm a huge of the show.
I went over to their bar,
they got their own restaurant over there.
It's like the number two live place to
play music now in Texas already or in
Dallas. They just passed house of Blues,
the fucking crushing it over there. So,
um, I dunno if you get a chance. I I man,
I asked all kinds of
Geeky fan questions too.
I'm trying to remember some
that won't ruin any episodes.
They get like 400 emails a day cause I
asked them like, how do you guys find,
how do you find all these fucking
cars? I know Richard, Zoe, Sam,
I'm going to go on the
interweb and blah blah blah.
They get 400 emails a day of people
with these cars that they want to sell.
Either they don't want to handle them or
the person who owned them passed away.
And, um, man,
you should see I got to shut up
cause I don't want to ruin any of,
so thank you to Richard Rawlings
for hooking me up over there.
Casey for giving me the ride and uh,
Jason and his lovely wife Linda
giving me the tour and everything.
I just had a great, great time and I
can't wait for the next season. So, uh,
if you don't watch it fast and
loud on discovery, look at that.
That was like a fucking 20 minute
commercial for him. Um, all right, let's,
let's move on to the, uh,
to the questions this week.
Ever so slight. Where are we at 36
minutes in. Okay. Uh, solar panels.
Last week I talked about,
I was thinking about maybe
getting solar panels off my house,
off my house on my house and uh,
I dunno if I want to go off the grid,
but whatever the city of Bacon
in the sun in his fucking house,
I might as well get something out of it.
Right. All right, so here we go. Hi Bill.
First off, huge fan of your
comedy podcasts. Thank you.
I saw you perform a Brian Regan
oh with Brian Regan cubs comedy.
While that was a, that was a bucket list
night for me to be able to perform it.
That guy show was absolutely hilarious.
Well thank you and thank you
for Brian Regan to um, anyway,
regarding your question about solar,
there is no solar power that
is completely off the grid.
You use all the energy that you can
provide through solar and the rest that
can't be provided by the sun like at
night or if it gets shady on your roof.
The utility provides, this is
called interconnection. Uh,
you save a ton of money and you
use clean energy in the process.
I worked for a solar company,
I promise this isn't a bullshit sales
pitch and I managed the construction
timeline so I've learned
a lot about this stuff.
Here's the link to my
company I worked for.
We install a lot in la
and in Boston as well too.
I think we're in like 12 different states.
Anyways,
thanks you for the awesome podcasts and
you know something about this Psoas Shit.
This, every person you talk
to says something different.
I watch people on Youtube
make up a solar thing. Um,
what a solar thing.
Put up their solar panels,
broke down how they worked and uh,
and how you could get off the grid,
but it was really, really,
really fucking involved.
Sky's digging a God damn trench. I can't
even know what the fuck was going on,
but I'm just like, all right, I don't
have room for a trench. All right.
My little piece of property here so I
don't, you know, I got room for a whole,
does that work?
I can't even know what he was doing.
They dug this translation stuff
like a fucking top in there.
Yeah.
I don't even know what the heck. I can't
even tell you what, what's going on.
But um, I will definitely,
I'll definitely look into it.
Um, hopefully I'll have more luck
with you guys and the fucking concept.
Put the roof on this house.
Okay.
Fucking assholes.
I told you what they did right.
They put the roof on the house
and then like the drain pipes,
because it's an old house,
old stupid design with a drain off was
it goes down into a pipe that actually
goes into like, uh, I don't, I have
like, uh, my attic is actually ever see,
seen John Malcovich or being,
being John Malcovich.
Remember they had that floor, we
had to walk around, bent over.
Like that's basically how much
space there is between, um,
the ceiling on my top
floor and then the roof.
I don't even know what
the purpose of it is.
All it is is just try it just traps air
that gets heated up and causes my house
to be hot. But anyways, that's what it is.
So the drain off of the water on the
roof goes into a pipe that goes in,
into the fucking crawl space and then
back out the front of the house and down
the side. So you take water from the
roof, you bring it into the house,
it's inside a pipe.
But nevertheless,
you're bringing into the fucking house
and God forbid that pipe bursts or you
have some fucking moron who disconnects
it when he's putting the new roof on and
forgets to hook it back up and
then tries to blame it. Not yet.
He blamed it on mobile, you know,
the fuck it all the blah blah blah.
And I'm just sitting there going, all
right, this is at least a year in court.
You know what? Why don't you
just get the fuck Outta here?
I'll just put in a goddamn claim.
You can't.
That's what I did cause I didn't
want to go to court. So, um, anyways,
I'm hoping you, you're better than
those guys. I mean, how couldn't you be?
All right. Here's my favorite one of
this week. A solar roadways debunked.
Um, I got a note from my
guy here, Andrew says,
a ton of people forwarded the same
link as the one in the email below.
I watched this, so you don't
have to, it's 30 minutes long.
Basically he bitches about
costs maintenance and the
efficiency is efficiency of
the perks. Advertising original video,
like heating, repairing the road. Yeah,
I actually watched the
first 10 minutes of it. Um,
I'll save my opinion until I read
this. Uh, Yo Billy, the sunburn kid.
I know you were pretty pumped up about
solar roads to be honest. So was I,
but someone's smart sat down and crunched
some numbers and brought up points is
why as to why solar roads
are economically in tech,
technically not feasible.
It's about 30 minutes long.
So if you got some time to
kill in any airport, check
it out. Well, you know, sir,
I watched the first
10 minutes of it. Uh,
he didn't debunk them.
He just brought up a bunch of questions.
He's just like a road has to be durable
and I would have some questions about,
I mean,
they showed a tractor run over the tiles,
but it was a small tractor and
they only did it once. Um, I,
I would like to see how these,
you know,
these things hold up when it's wet
out and you need water to run off.
And he just brought up a bunch
of fucking questions. You know,
he didn't debunk them. He did
basically, basically what he did.
It's like 50% what you have to do. You
can't have somebody just come in and, hey,
these are brand new roads. Can I make
them? Oh, okay. You think they're good,
you think they're going to work okay.
I mean obviously you can't do that,
but it's 50% that, which is smart.
You got to ask the right questions.
And then the other side is anytime
he tried to do something new,
there's always people saying
it's not going to work. You know,
and this guy in his half hour,
I'm sure he brings,
he brought up a number of
things that would be a problem.
It doesn't mean they can't
work. Okay. So I don't,
I wouldn't say they were debunked.
I would just say somebody asked a bunch
of fucking questions and rather than
just one, what he does is he just
throws it out there. It's like,
why don't you contact the people at the
solar road who tried to make the solar
roads and actually get some
answers and get some fucking, uh,
or maybe order some tiles and tried to
do some experiments yourself rather than
wasting people's time with the half
hour of questions and speculation.
That's basically what it was. So I
wouldn't say that it was debunked. Um,
but you know, you throw up
three pointers for half an hour,
some of them are going to
go in even if you suck.
So I'm sure a couple of his concerns
were true, but uh, you know, I mean,
look at electric cars
since way back in the day,
people who are, they show
up, they're fucking up.
Like people actually question the
power of electric electricity.
It powers the entire fucking city
can light up a whole fucking city.
And I get a Prius and my own mother,
my own mother is going,
can it go up a hill now mom?
I just got to get out and start walking.
It's great for my weight.
And look at that. They sell,
they're underpowered and
their this and their that.
First of all,
the Prius is not an electric car.
It's not even a fucking 50% electric car.
It's like an 8% electric car.
That's what it is from like zero.
I've told you this Gus,
for years from zero to
seven miles an hour,
that car runs an electric power and then
switches over to gas for the rest of
the time.
And if you drive with a lead foot,
you're going to get maybe 25
miles a gallon. But if you listen,
if you listen to the engine,
okay.
And you don't stomp on the gas and drive
like a fucking maniac and slam on the
brakes, you can get, you know, I don't,
I wouldn't say 40 miles a gallon. Yeah,
you can get like 35,
but it's great. Perfect
car. If you live in, in the
city. I absolutely love the
fucking thing. So anyways,
so you had that,
I bought that thing in October
of 2007 and now look at these,
these Tesla cars. I actually
wrote in one of those, uh,
the end of last year before I wrote in
Casey's fucking truck, Jesus Christ,
which probably gets two feet
to the gallon, especially
the way he was driving it.
MMM.
Those Tesla cars are fucking amazing.
And you can drive from last I checked
from San Diego, all you have to Vancouver.
MMM.
You know, they have recharge stations
from San Diego. All we have to Vancouver.
And I think recently someone just
drove one across the country.
So it's not like that guy in
the speculation video. Um, I'm,
I got to look that one up or you
should look it up or whatever. But um,
I'm actually, uh, I'm leaning towards
that fucking thing. Thinks bad ass.
You walk up to,
when you turn it on,
like the door handles are flush against
the car and you walk up and things pop
out. I'm sure why the cars do that.
But I never seen it, you know,
it was cool to me. The only thing
I didn't like about the car is it,
it has like a supersized fucking
iPad right in the dashboard.
Um,
and that just seemed like that would be
really distracting for somebody like me.
I need like a shade just to sort
of pull that thing down. But um,
I'm actually thinking
of maybe getting one.
How's that kind of like the idea
that they just sorta one price.
Like you don't go in there and
there's none of that haggling. Um,
so you don't feel like a
pussy when you walk out.
Cause I don't give a shit how
many fucking videos you watch.
You still get your ass handed
to you. Um, but either way.
Let's bring in the birthday
girl. Hi Neha. Come on in.
Got to bring in the
birthday girl over here.
MMM.
Just trying to find something that
she can relate to. NBA. Oh, Bill.
Not asking you to rat for 20 minutes.
Oh, there we go. The lovely knee.
Everybody happy birthday to you.
Happy Birthday to you
will be birthday dear Ni.
Uh,
happy birthday to you.
Yeah, sorry. That was beautiful.
It was in its own sad way.
Um, how'd you like your cupcake?
I loved that. There you go.
You made me a cookie.
My favorite kind of cupcake too,
which is very sweet to put it with candle,
candle Roman candle in it saying yeah,
happy birthday. It was very nice thing.
And you didn't wash shit in
my face. I did it. All right,
well happy birthday a whole bunch
more that you made. So you know.
Well that's the thing. All my
recipes, p's and q's suite on.
Well the thing is is all my
recipes come from my mother.
So they all serve like 10
people so well a cupcake recipes
are going to be for like
they made more than 30 yeah,
I stopped after I went to rounds
through what did I make, what does it,
was it, was it six and a
tray or eight and the tray,
there's like 18 to 20 of them out there.
Well nobody makes one cupcake. So yeah,
any kind of recipe is going to be,
why didn't you just make,
make like six six is perfect.
They never think about like they don't,
they never think about the lonely
people when they make a cookbook. Well,
the thing is you could put the batter
in for six and cook the six and then
freeze the rest of your battery and just
have it for the next time you want to
make cupcakes. So it's not like it's
a complete waste, but all right.
Who's going to give you the exact
measurements for like one or two cupcakes?
That's, that's silly. Well, you know what?
I think that'd be a great
idea for a cookbook.
What cupcakes for one?
The loaner.
The loaner cookbook or just single?
Yeah,
like when you're fucking single
sitting there trying to do the math.
You know Zay serves eight.
It's just like,
I'm fucking 22 I'm trying
to make spaghetti over here.
Why don't they just make what? That's
why you have left. But the thing is,
that's why it's good to have leftovers.
You free is a shit and you have
it for later. Well it's not,
it's not bad now because you can
go on the Internet. Like today,
I'm sitting there looking at that fucking
cane sugar and they're asking me in
the bag,
it says two pounds of cane sugar and they
wanted a certain amount of ounces and
I'm sitting there and all they have is
like a quarter cup. So I go, I was like,
how many cups are in a pound? And they're
like, well, cups is more of a like a uh,
size. Now the size, what is
the word? Like a, like a did.
They couldn't figure like it's
not a weight cup is not a weight.
It's more like a fucking handful
kind of looking at it like that.
So what I actually did was I took out
one of your little sports fucking things
that you drink out of that
has ounces on the sides.
So the protein shakes then yes, that
works. Yeah. Well that's why the,
the thing was a disaster once I got out.
It's like a bakery exploded in
there. Yeah. Lauer everywhere. Yep.
Mix thislike kicked on the countertops
and on the floor and it's ride little
white puddles. That's right.
You're like a little kid.
Whenever you make something,
you make that biggest fucking
mess I have ever seen.
The kitchen is a disaster.
That's why I like it.
You've got like stains all
over your apron. You know,
you're sweating a little bit.
You're Harry. You're like what?
Stepping around and your socks in
the kitchen sliding around in flower.
You're all like stressed out. You're all
red in the face. I wasn't stressed out.
You weren't sets at this time, but other
times you've made stuff. It's been fun.
That's when I have learned to stay
away. Here's the kitchen. No, no.
Here's the thing. That was, that was
the younger me who flipped out all, no,
I flip out a year ago. Quit going for
the joke. Come on, I'm getting better.
Um, yeah, and also back in the
dead. Didn't have a neighbor.
You've got to have an apron.
Yay. Bernie fans or don't mess.
He just laid it out on the front of
them and you just keep marching forward.
Leave the casualties, bind.
It's fucking phenomenal. Um,
it was delicious though. I
really appreciate it. And
your gifts were amazing.
Of course they were killed it.
That's birthday. And of course I did.
And you know what?
You know I killed it because you always
figure out what I'm going to get you is.
I just played like I was a moron.
I really hate that though.
And can I just say I really,
you drove me crazy with that yesterday.
You were driving me nuts.
You were actually mad at me.
That was the oldest trying not to be,
but you were really pushing my buttons.
You were trying to make me mad.
See that's the thing you're
toying with me though. Huh?
You know exactly what I'm talking about.
I emailed you something like
a month ago to say, Hey,
if you're wondering what to get me for
my birthday cause I know you're busy.
I know you're on the road and all this
other stuff. Look at you and help you out.
I'm telling you what I want also, you
know it's like I'm not like a little kid.
You know what I mean? I got to tell you
exactly what I wanted. Like give you,
leads you in the right direction.
What a little kids say what?
Say what they don't want.
Why mean you know,
there's a little kid as a breadth
of you're like, hey, I have a toy,
get out of here, beat it. But when
you're older set, what happens?
Like specific things that you know, maybe
you'd like to guess. He let people know.
My parents asked me all the time,
what do you want for your birthday?
What do you want for your birthday?
Because nobody has time to sit around
and like figure out what you want.
So you know now what I did this year.
But that's what you did because you
took what I wanted and then you kind of
riffed on it and you've got a bunch
of stuff to surround. No, it was,
it was wonderful. But my point is you made
me cry like, Hey, you still took credit.
You took what I said and then your
riffed on it and I didn't actually will
listen to you this year and four months
ago and I figured out what the fuck you
wanted and then you did your usual
thing because you are an organizing.
You like you,
you're an organized person literally
to the point that you're organizing.
My shopping for what I get you now,
one of the great things
about giving somebody a gift,
it's the surprise where they're like, they
like me out to brunch and you're like,
all right, I gotta get you home cause
I gotta go shopping for your birthday.
Like the, how's that supposed to make me
feel? I'm sitting there like, uh, okay.
This is why. This is why I did that.
Because you emailed me something.
I knew you wanted this shit. Okay. Now
if I just went out and got it for you,
I mean, why don't you just fucking,
even when the, when the mailman comes,
he hands it to me and then I throw
it at you. When you're sitting there,
it takes no fucking
imagination whatsoever, right?
So I knew you wanted it.
I knew I was going to get it for you,
but I'm like,
how the fuck is it still a
surprise that she gets it?
So what I did was I
acted like I wasn't an,
I already knew the other things that
I were going to, I was going to get.
I knew where the hell they were.
I waited to the last second to get it.
She thought I was like a an unthoughtful
jackass and it worked in his life.
Fucking sharp.
Why would you buy?
Why would you make yourself seem like
you know a last minute jackass like that?
Like why would it just to torture me
and I'm telling you what torturing me
because you cannot just give me the
gift and be like, here you go, honey.
You have to have some other little
thing where you throw me off my game.
You give me all in a tizzy
and then it's like, oh wait,
he actually did the perfect thing.
Why? Why do you play those songs?
That's exactly what type of things that
you accuse women of doing and you do it
to me all the time. This is why,
because when I don't do that,
you get exactly what I'm going to
get you and it's fucking annoying.
Fucking and I wrapped something.
You already know what's in it.
You make me feel like an idiot.
Why do you feel like it?
Just cause I guess what it is. Guess your
peak. You look that time when I came,
when I went Christmas shopping.
Oh my God, yes we are.
Yes we are told you not.
See what you brought up is when you know
you're going to bring up a good point
with your woman and she immediately
starts trying to talk over you.
I do the same thing. Yes, he too.
So I'm pulling up in the car.
You knew I was going Christmas shopping
for you. I'm getting out of the car.
I opened the hatch back to our
sweet, innocent little hybrid. Right.
I take the bag out that has the name of
the fucking store and I glanced and I
glance over at the house and you're
standing there like a specter looking out
the window. My fucking heart. My
heart like jolted. When I looked up,
you know you had a
creepy look on your face.
You were doing something sneaky. No you
weren't. And then you didn't see me.
Can I show you? Can I show you what you
were doing? All right, fine. This is,
this is what you were doing.
I looked when I,
I'm looking at the house and I
look up and you would like this.
Nobody can see me.
So what you're sitting there looking
like some weird like stalkers.
That's what you were doing. No,
I did it. Yes. As you were doing,
you're a spoiled Brat and you,
you,
you wanted to see what was in the
spoiled Brat. Alright, you're spoiled.
He's spoiled me. Oh God.
Blaming the victim once again.
Now here's the deal.
No, that's why I did it.
I like to try to surprise you. If I'm
going to spend all my fucking money on,
on some goddamn thing here, I
want you to, I, I want, I want
to throw how much money it
costs for you to get in my face.
You didn't have to say how much it costs
just by saying, if I'm going to say,
am I really gonna lose this? I'm not
going to lose this one. It's my birthday.
It's like, oh yeah. Oh my God.
All right, let's go. Let's because
yeah, because it's like a sport for you
to figure out what the fuck I got you.
It's annoying. I never tried it for
you to always throw me off my game.
You know it's a sports for me
teaching you how to use a microphone.
Just talk into it. Oh, okay. There you
go. You couldn't hear me before. Well,
I hear you and then you're over here.
No,
you only go over here when
you're mentoring somebody
else. That's what you do.
Or when you go lady. There
you go. That's all it is.
That's the mic technique. There you go.
All right, we're going to talk NBA here.
Nini, the NBA, the NBA National
Basketball Association.
A professional league. Now with
basketball, I know what it's like. Soccer.
You use your hands but not your feet.
You can't kick the ball. It's reversed.
Soccer. I'm swearing when I'm going to
possibly know about the MBA. But anyway,
let's, let's go ahead and read it. Well,
I mean I have to read the questions here.
Okay,
there's,
there's no penalty and just tapping out
on what NBA bill not asking you to ran
for 20 minutes on this. Cause I know
not everyone cares about basketball,
but seriously,
the NBA,
the NBA is so rigged. How can announcers
and former players not be up in arms?
Lebron got three files in the
first quarter. I Hate Lebron,
but Christ's let's have a fair game.
I think the trick is to watch shitty
teams and hope shitty teams make it to the
playoffs.
So there's no incentive to
Suede the momentum if the
raptors played the jazz and
the championships.
There's no superstars, uh,
help or to help or to penalize
it. Yeah, I mean I think it's,
look at any sport, the top players
definitely get preferential treatment.
I mean there's the Tom Brady rule is,
there's all kinds of shit that goes on,
but I just, you know, that's
one of those ones where look,
I mean they make more money
if it goes more games. I, I,
I just feel like I've already
said what I said. Okay.
I'm not going to keep reiterating it
either you believe it or you don't.
I know for years, I said it was fixed
and then they found a mobbed up ref,
you know,
who was actually fixing games and fuck
the Sacramento Kings out of a series
against the Lakers and the Lakers
went on to win a championship.
They literally affected who the fuck won
the championship that year or this guy
did. And then everybody,
when I was vindicated and I
was right just when lag. Ah,
it was just one guy.
It's just one guy.
I think it's in their best interest to
have the stars of the big teams in the
finals and for it to go
more than four games. Okay.
And I think, you know, those
reps get paid by the game,
those fuck in arenas,
you know, more games,
more concession, more tickets,
more commercial, more money. So,
and I think that, uh, that plays a fucking
roll consciously or subconsciously.
I'm not saying that they sit down, I
just think that it's fucking, I just, I,
my thing I'm done saying it's fixed.
I'll just say that the reps have way
too much power and they have to stop
dictating the tempo of the game. I
would like the players, you know,
I would rather have that.
All right. There we go.
But either way don't blow in Lebron's
ear even though that was funny as fucking
hell. Did you see that? This guy on a,
on the fucking Pacers,
I forget his name and not a big hoop guy.
He blew in the bronze. Yeah,
there was sitting there.
I think they were both sitting there.
You know when you get
your hands on your knees,
I don't know if they're waiting for the
jump ball or something and he was sort
of not quite perpendicular to the side
of Lebron's face, but he just sorta went
right into his ear. And what was funny
was it took Lebron for like half a second.
Then he sort of smile
and shook his head like
so it didn't have the desired effect or
he was hoping he was going to get like
when will Smith slap
that guy who kissed him?
I think he was trying and then get
him off his game. Lebron James. Well,
I mean he's like a,
he's like a fucking x man out there.
The guys that Goddamn Superhero,
although I got to tell you,
I get so turned off by the NBA.
I don't understand what all this screaming
and yelling is after of you make a
basket. What do you mean
screaming you like they're
excited. Like they're like, no,
like they're mad at somebody.
You can't see the yelling.
Just looking at the crowd yelling.
Lebron James took the ball when coast
to coast like I've seen my entire life.
He's not the first guy
to go coast to coast.
He dunks the ball and when he's done he
first walks and he starts glaring at the
crowd and then he's going all
the way up to sideline. No,
I mean what he's saying is he just
like all hyped and like, yeah.
Yeah. I like would they always hyped,
which you always hyped. You give,
you gave a high five.
He's sitting there screaming and yelling,
thumping his fucking chest. They're out
there acting like that. It's like, dude,
you put a ball through a hoop.
I know you will.
You're the one of the greatest
to ever fucking did it,
but you, you're not Jordan.
I never saw Jordan do that. He doesn't
have to be Jordan. He's limping on.
I'm just saying why I don't like it.
I'm not saying he can't do
it through Kevin Garnett.
I swear to God it's
like he has Tourette's.
He does any of these walking up to the
line like talking to himself and every
other word is fuck.
You can clearly see that the guy say
and fuck and I don't understand why.
It's just, it's, it's bizarre. Every other
word out of your mouth as fuck, you know,
but I'm not on fucking T.
Oh, I guess I am on TV.
Yes you are on TV and oh
no, no, no, no, no. That's,
I'll tell you why this is different.
That would be like if I told a joke
and then it killed and as the crowds
laughing and applauding, I
was standing up there, go
to the show.
It's stupid.
I just do your job and shut the fuck up.
That's the difference. All
right. That's, and that's why my,
my thing is I can't like,
like your,
your applauding yourself.
You're more if I can't even get to the
level of amazement that they are about
themselves. That's what turns
me off about the fucking game.
You ever read catcher in
the Rye, Nia? Oh my God.
Fucking catcher in the Rye analogy,
you always make. I'll tell you why,
because the catcher in the rye,
that's that dead fucking thing when
he sees that great piano player,
but the guy knows he's great
and he's making that face,
that Ge Smith thing and
it's just like, yeah, dude,
you're up your own ass right now.
You don't need me and I'm not going to
sit there and watch your fucking Jerky
self off after you just did something
that a bunch of other people have already
fucking done.
It drives me.
It drives me fucking nuts and all I know
is that little kids see it now and then
they're going to be doing that.
Even go on a little kid's games and
they've got to fucking take like a diaper
shot. Then he'd go, yeah,
high pitch voice coach on the fucking
thing and I'm going to say they're going
to want,
I'm going to want to throw a hotdog.
Them really are an old fogy now with your
complaining about how these young kids
go out there and they're thumping their
chest and they're just go out there and
do your job. Yeah, I mean I look,
there's definitely an element of that.
I'll even take 60% of that, but 40% of
it as I'm writing. What are you doing?
I never, Magic Johnson never did
that shit. Jordan didn't do it,
but they talk shit to each
other occasionally. You know,
there'd be a second you didn't turn
around glare at the crowd like,
like,
like you just fucking diff
painted somebody on planet
Krypton and then fucking
go down the side, scraped
up, screaming and yelling.
That's where the camera's though
with this crazy. Maybe it's,
maybe it's for the cameras and maybe it's,
you know,
you know when the crazy homeless guy gets
on the subway and just starts yelling
and then you just look down at the floor,
go and please don't pick me.
Please don't pick me. Don't look
at them. Those are the rules.
They are they doing it for the clips
when they do like the commercials where
they play the music and stuff and they
show all the clips in the game and they
show the guy's like, yeah, like looking
out at the crowd. Maybe it's for that.
Of course playing up
to the fucking camera.
They all hang out with each other on
the same fucking yacht and go, hey,
let's all jump on the same team
and then we'll become a dynasty.
And then you know,
then the,
the announcers who make money announcing
the NBA so they're never going to
criticize it and then
they just say the saved,
I'll tell you what are you getting a
breath of Magic Johnson aura or Michael
Jordan because they are accomplishing
the same thing on paper,
but they're not doing what those guys did.
And when those guys did it,
you did it through the draft and
maybe a blockbuster trait. Okay.
There was way more cerebral back then.
How you had to put it together, team,
you had to lean way more
on your fucking scouts.
He didn't have a bunch of players all
jump on the same team and then you jump on
this team.
Okay.
He jumps on this fucking team and becomes
like this three headed fucking monster
just stopping on all these
other goddamn tea. I mean,
well why don't I just watch it go
fucking go play a bunch of kids,
a high school team. I mean I know
it's not that bad, but it did that.
That's what's killing
it for me. Okay. Yeah.
You know it was funny.
You're not even a sports fan or whatever
and I said why she called me in for
this one we've been wanting, I call you
and you said you, I'm on the podcast.
Yeah, cause I know I am wanting to
talk about other things. Not the NBA.
All right. Office bitch. Oh is
that it? Is that a good one? I,
it sounds like something that you would
want me to just because it has bitch in
it. Like, oh, that's good.
A ladies a billion in here.
Okay. What is it saying? Well,
this is how long you were unbelievable.
I just did the NBA. That's a guy topic.
You didn't like that one. So now I'm
giving you a lady talking to add this one.
I want to hear this one. I'm
with you. I'm like, yeah,
you didn't sound like you
were you selling, get back
pedaling. Okay. All right.
This guy writes Billy Parmesan
and then writes Palmer. John like,
I don't know how to read.
Yeah. Why? What do I say?
Tommy John as John [inaudible] permission,
the lead farmers.
John,
I'm Italian and very much so at that I
speak Italian and I'm first generation
Italian. Ciao. This guy,
Italian prego. Prego. Vino Vino.
I work with the girl who
claims she's Italian,
but she really isn't at all
Hashtag Middle Easter. Um,
I mean, how does he, oh, I mean,
her grandmother may have
fucked a Sicilian. Oh.
Or She's all of garden Italian,
you know, less than one 16th.
Italians are not fucking around about
who's Italian. It's not, it's high.
And then if you're Cecelia, that's
like a different thing. Yeah.
You guys don't play with that.
They don't fuck around the same way gas
monkey does not fuck around when they
build a car. I told them that story
right in Casey's truck. Jesus Christ. Um,
anyways, in the office,
she's constantly, uh,
calling me and a few other Italians,
guineas and Gumbos.
She says it like she's one of us and
most times in a manner that really forces
it into the conversation. Like, hey,
Gainey's don't grease up my stapler.
Now I'm not completely insulted,
but the catch is she's black.
A year ago she complained to the human
resources that a coworker who had
listened to rap music on his headphones
at lunch would mouth lyrics that weren't
meant for him, I. E. The n word.
There really is no proof that even mouth
the words because he sat facing the
wall and all she knew was that he was
listening to Jay z's new album at the time
and assumed he mouths all the words,
none of which were audible by the way.
Um, how do you know this
if you weren't there? Um,
so one day last week she was calling
us dumb guineas and asked if my friend
Leonardo yes, that is his name. If
he could ring out his hair over her.
Oh my God. Cause the place she ordered
from didn't give her enough dressing.
The Garner Salad. Wow. Wow. That
is a funny joke though. If you're,
if you're cool with somebody,
that's fucking hilarious. Uh,
the funny thing because those are the
rules hardly offensive if you're not,
if you're not. Yeah. Cause that's
one of the things if your friends,
if someone was,
you know,
some Italian guy was breaking my balls
would being a pasty freckled cunt.
And then I came up with that ring your
hair out over the salad. I mean that's,
that's fucking, I might have him for the
week. You'd have to come back with the,
I don't know what the funny thing about
the situations that Leo doesn't have
greasy hair at all.
Oh yeah.
I mean it's a huge stretch
of a joke and a stereotype.
It's hacky and not even insulting.
The insulting part is that
she thinks nothing of it.
I know what you're going to say.
This is one of those things.
You just got to let go. But I
didn't, I stood up and said, listen,
you're not Italian if you're Italian
than I'm black because I'm Sicilian and
we've all heard the true romance speech.
That was the end of it.
Did I handle that right? Cause I sure as
hell wasn't going to let myself become,
I'm an HR whore. Uh, thanks
for listening. Um, I think
you did the right thing because
I know you don't want,
why don't you go first name?
What do you, what do you think?
No, I actually think he did
the right thing to, cause
the girl says she's Italian,
but you say she's black,
but like dis meaning like she looks black,
like she looks like me or like she's
actually has said I am black and Italian
because maybe she's biracial or whatever.
So I mean the whole thing about
she's not really Italian, Duh Duh.
That's why I was laughing at
how Italians are very, you know,
protective about who can say
they're Italian and who was not.
So she might be biracial. Right.
But the thing about it is, you know,
in this country they have that whole like,
what is it, the one, eighth, whatever,
drop paper bag test,
all that kind of shit where it's like if
you've got a drop of black blood in you,
you're black. That's the way
it's considered in this country.
That's the way it was set up in America.
So maybe that's why you're feeling like
you're not even Italian, you're black.
So that all aside. Yeah, for her,
I'm making a joke saying like dumb
guineas and Goombas and stuff.
Like if you're offended by it,
you should definitely tell her.
I'm offended by that. I know you said
that you were Italian, but I just,
I find that kind of speech,
you know, offensive,
so please don't say it around me. I don't
like that. And I think that is better.
I had to think it is better to confront
the person then running off to HR.
You know the whole thing with the guy
mouthing the lyrics, the Jay z's album,
and he was facing the wall like,
listen. Yeah, unless you were there.
I mean he probably had a
conversation with this guy.
That's why he's coming at like that.
She said I was melting the n word and
she couldn't even see me. I used to too.
I mean, but is a, here's the thing.
Here's the thing. This is the only sheet.
This is the deal. She
sounded a little nuts, right?
And this thing,
all those jokes are funny.
If it's done the right way and she's not
doing it the right way. And if she look,
I think if she came to this guy and
said, hey, I'm whatever, one, eighth,
Italian or whatever,
and talked about Italians
in a respectful way, um,
that this guy would embrace her, that
she would, that she, her Italian blood,
and then they would have
this bond where he'd be like,
oh that's the Italian in you see I knew
blah blah. If you come at them that way,
if you start going, hey,
if you day go fuck good,
right, right. Quick Grecian up the
floors, all the whole thing about,
give me some of your hair cause I
don't have enough. I got to tell you,
layer it the fuck off money. I can't, I
can't read that without laughing. Yeah,
it's fine. It's fine. But
now it's, it's, it's wrong.
I'm going to say that especially if she's
going to turn around and be upset that
someone's listening to rap music in their
headphones and Malbec word that don't,
boards that aren't four years.
Yeah. JC, we'll take JC,
we'll take your white money.
You'll take your white money. Those
lyrics are not for, you know this,
I will,
you and all your friends can
finance my next big purchase.
But these lyrics are not for you.
What is the rule on that?
Can a white guy in his car can sing log?
Yeah,
right to the rap music.
I'm not going to tell you what
are alone when I'm not there.
I can't. What do, what is,
what would you say as an African American
is the protocol if you're singing
along? I mean, it's just a song, you know,
sunshine on my shoulders makes me happy.
Are you allowed to say the end of the
front end, but then what? Rap Song?
So somebody has already singing a
song. Okay. You're on a bus, right?
It's a terrible day for your knee. You're
on a bus. Oh, Jesus. What are you going?
What happened? Um, as long as I'm
not in the back, I'm all right. Um,
so somebody's got their little
fucking iPod on right? Or phone thing,
whatever. Right. And they're
singing to the songs, right?
And the first song they sing it is that,
you know,
sunshine on my show and you laugh and
like wow, this guy is singing out loud,
he's singing off key.
You kind of laughing to yourself,
but he's got his iPod on shuffle.
Okay.
And then the next one
is that Wu Tang Song,
right? And he's singing
along to old dirty bastard,
tried to run game on a WHO's buck wild
and he starts singing along with that.
I think you should do it
just the way you did it.
Do it the way I feel like the silent
listen when I went to go see Jay z would
you get mad? No, but at this, this is
a good example of that. Once it goes,
see Jay Z and Kanye the watch
the throne at the staple center,
you know the whole stadium arena full
of people, all black, white, whoever,
and everybody was singing along to all
the songs and it wasn't in the context of
it. It was like, yeah, cause it's not like
the white people are going to be like,
Ooh, I can't. It's like
we're all singing along.
It's all enjoying the
music is not a big deal.
So if there's a big crowd of people
singing the n word, like is it different
than the white person who's like trying
to show you how down they are and
they're like all in your, what do
you call it again? Appropriating the,
what do you call it? Oh, cultural
appropriation. Yeah. Yeah.
If you're like a white person that was
like, yeah, I'm down for my niggas.
You know how we need to do with it and
I'm going to look at you like you're
fucking crazy.
I want to do that tomorrow
because you know it, it's,
it's,
it's ridiculous for you to do that.
But it used to shock me in New York
when I would hear these kids that were
seemingly, now I'm like the guy that
wrote in, not black but like Latina, like,
you know, Dominican or
Puerto Rico, Puerto Rican,
and they call themselves
Niggas all the time.
And I wasn't aware of that when I first
moved to New York. So I was like, what?
And then I just realized he had made,
they do that too.
I remember that it was okay for them.
I remember when I was at in and out
Burger [inaudible] sitting outside the one
on a sunset boulevard and I was
sitting there and there was this dude,
I think he was Mexican, which once again
he's probably Middle Eastern. They get,
they get, they get mistook for everything.
Mexicans, no Middle Eastern people.
Oh yes. It once they, once they
get out of the stereotypical,
God dammit,
it's 110 degrees out here.
I'm going to wear this robe
thing when they just start, well,
when they know I'm talking to Middle
Eastern people. Okay. Once they,
once when they were Americanized
fucking clothes, they can go,
oh yeah, cause they're, then they're just
brown. I knew, I knew a guy for years.
I thought he was Italian and it onstage,
he was pretending to be Italian.
Right. And it turned out he
was Lebanese. I had no idea.
No idea. You had the
fucking, you know what?
Isn't there another famous comedian who
kind of had an Italian persona and it
turns out he's actually
Jewish. She, I don't know.
Nia Is there are
fucking set me up here.
All right, let's go to a,
here we go.
A dear Billy goat.
I was listening to old
some old podcasts and a,
you are sharing your feelings
on movies you'd recently seen.
What was the last movie theater experience
you enjoyed? I mean, the movie itself,
not all the necking net that goes on
in the back row. You old bloodhound.
Oh, he's using those old words. Just this
is just him acting like I'm fucking old.
Um, all right. The movie in the
theater all, I probably would,
I would have saw it with you.
I'm not a big wolf was the last one
we saw in the theater. Oh my God.
Which I hated. Hated. Hated. Hated, hated.
I got to tell you this,
it was worth seeing Leonardo's the
actress that played his wife, Jeez,
Margot Robbie. She's gorgeous. She's
Australian. Did you know that? Uh,
no. I just, you know, oh,
she was like, you know,
what was great about her was she was
totally naked and she's still within that.
It didn't look dirty. She was just,
she was a goddess. Gorgeous. Okay.
I mean, yeah, when I look at
her. But did you like the movie?
That's what he wants to know.
Was your,
your the last time you were in a movie
and really enjoy the movie itself was uh,
I don't,
I can't remember what was done in the
movie theater before that because I feel
like we very rarely go to the
movie theater. I what did,
we must have saw something since then.
Move walls from the walls of Wall Street.
I have to see again why?
Because it can suck another,
my thesis, it wasn't that
bad. It was definitely law.
It was too long and it was like
repetitive. It's like I get it.
These guys are drug taking assholes.
How many more scenes of this do we need?
And it's like,
I appreciate the chemistry between
Leonardo Dicaprio and Jonah Hill,
but it's like, all right,
already he just, you know,
Scorsese just let the camera
run and run and run and run.
And I will say that some of those
sales meetings, dammit, we're so long.
I started to feel like I worked at
the company. I thought that they were,
they were kind of, uh, in real time,
they were really trying to hammer home
the fact that these were just these
underhanded, dirty kind of excessive
eighties guys. And it's like,
we got it.
The opening shot was them tossing in
the one we live in this world now.
We get who they are. You know what
I do want to see? I want to see the,
I don't know how to say it
then I say, yeah, let's go.
So I kept saying male, Male,
a fuss. I just kept seeing Malan.
Maleficence that's not a word, right?
It's the name of the character. It's the
name of the evil queen in Snow White.
That's her name. Is it Latin for
something? I have no idea. Alright,
dear Billy goat.
I was listening some old to some old
podcasts and you are a shift. Read that.
Oh, you fucking crazy. I didn't
even, I didn't even realize that. Ps,
I love the x men. He says, and
uh, please remind listeners. Oh,
oh,
oh, okay. Hey, this is just my,
please remind a family listeners that
which family member would you fuck
dilemmas are hacky and won't
make it to the podcast? Yeah.
Why would you even ask
a question like that?
Because some people want to have sex with
a fucking family member and they want
to feel like they're not
alone in this world. They do.
I don't know. All right. Oh,
they're just doing it's,
I hate those weird leg.
Would you rather fuck your
mother or fuck your dog?
Like what I talked to even
put out a doubt. Well,
depends on the fence on what kind of dog
it is and how much fight does it have
in it?
A dilemma.
Would you rather give up blow jobs
for the rest of your life or cheese?
Cheesy. Cheesy. Of course you'd
give up. She's absolutely,
I give up cheese at fucking less dairy,
less stomach aches.
I wouldn't get bound
up. Less bloating. Wait,
do I get more blow jobs to
doll the cheese I don't eat.
Does that go into the
more blow jobs he goes,
this includes the fake cheese like
cheese whiz or Mac and cheese. Dude.
I fucking hate that. She's,
that's, that's why I can,
I can never get on board with the Philly
cheese steak that have the whiz on it.
If that stuff, that was the perfect
name for two whiz as an pis.
Like if cheese took a piss, that's
what it is. She's Wiz. She's Biz. Yeah,
it's fucking gross.
I wonder if that's why they call it that,
but maybe it's who do you know what it is?
It's probably some process shit.
Something is scrape it off the top of
the bottom of something. Yeah. You know,
for years we will throw on this out.
Then we added a little something to it
and all kinds of preservatives and salt
and stuff so it can stay in that little
aerosol can for that longer than you
live on the food chain. It's below the
hot dog. Cheez whiz. I mean cheese was,
I mean that's like that's there with
fluffer nutter that's in there with like,
I mean cheese fluffer
nutter mellow spread.
Like it's like yummy toxic waste.
It's just horrific.
Like that's the kind of shit you
eat and your body is just like,
what the fuck is this? Yeah. Where do
we put this? And it just like that.
It's trans rat shit.
Like it just sticks it wherever.
It can put it twice to spread
it out through your body.
Yeah. I'm not into Jesus.
You'll,
you'll never see it in the house.
It's not something that I'm into so you
don't have to worry about that. Okay,
good friend. Did you talk Kim
and Kanye is wedding. Alrighty.
What I thought maybe you were talking
about Kim and Kanye is wedding.
I don't know because I
want to talk about that.
They already bought topical stuff first.
They already have a fucking kid,
you know stupid. What do you
mean? What's stupid about it?
You already had a kid. What
do you what? So now what?
We're getting married so I
can be like, oh my God. Hey,
I'll soon before all you already
have one. It's dumb. It's dumb.
You talking about,
I'm saying,
are you saying that people who leave the
kids shouldn't get married if they're
not married? No. They should get married.
If they want to but they shouldn't
make a big fucking deal out of it. Oh,
but this is Kim and Kanye were thought
that was such a waste of a castle there.
Now let's, they had there. They did.
They do it at first sight.
They had their dinner like they're,
they're like rehearsal
dinner or whatever ever Psi.
And then they got married in this old
castle in Florence and I have to say,
I don't know,
I'm looking at the pictures,
which is hilarious because they're
supposed to be so private and we're not
selling our pictures everywhere.
People magazine is like practically
a guest at the whole funnel.
This cell until one and then
all your books. Yeah. Yeah.
Which I'm what do you think they're going
to have to divorce that parliament in
London,
but I'm looking at the pictures. I got
it. I don't know. I think they look,
they look really happy. It
sounds so cheesy, but it's
true. I'm like, I was good.
I was very skeptical of it,
but I have to say they look super happy
and I thought I was going to be all I
rolly and all the pictures and the time
smile anymore facet he that's the thing
is smiling and all those pictures they,
I mean of course it's also for the second
car accident when he got the that that
the thing going there. Yeah. He
always has like a, the the bitch,
the bitch base, his resting phase is
bitch face. Like when he doesn't move it,
he's just kinda sitting there. He looks
angry like that. He just has that.
You kind of have it all when he has,
you kind of had that resting
phase where you look pissed off.
I definitely have that,
but my job doesn't look like it's made
out of like the same jar of like the tin
man. You're like that. Those rural
robots, the initial ones you make with,
they just sort of,
he yeah,
but they had is jargon all broken
so it's going to be a little weird.
Oh that's right.
And then he wrote a song about you,
one of the studio and made a video about
how awesome he was that he was in the
studio with survives.
That he had a wife that he
had a jaw wired shut. Yeah.
Oh man, you gotta film this. God,
I can't believe how awesome I am.
That's when I literally started feeling
old is just the absolute fucking just,
I mean, I don't know if it, cause
everybody started doing yoga or whatever.
Just the self blowing,
blowing, blowing, blowing.
That's just goes on like where it's just
like [inaudible] people are amazed with
how fucking amazing they are. The second
they get to that fucking level, I just,
I can't watch it. It's just, it's
gross. You gotta be your, your,
your own cheerleader though. You know what
I mean? You gotta be your own hype man.
Doesn't mean you gotta be an arrogant
ass. That's very true. Yeah. Look,
you fucking negative shit. I'm getting
nowhere. I can't do this. Then you got,
fuck this. I've got to do
something positive. I've got
to go to the gym. Come on,
Bill. You can do this, but
blah, blah, blah, blah.
That doesn't mean I've got
to have a look on my face.
Like I just conquered a country by
myself and start yelling at people.
This is really,
I just feel like this is kind of ironic
coming from a man whose job it is to
stand on stage and make people laugh,
which is what I do.
But it's also a part of it is like giving
your own opinions about stuff and sort
of like, you know, this is how I feel.
And of course it's for labs. But I mean,
I'm not saying what you and
Kanye do or they die one stages.
I'm a moron who doesn't
read, who has add, right?
If you really listened to it,
that's all I'm saying for an hour.
No one ever thinks that about you though.
No, they just seem angry Leprechaun.
But the thing is,
you know what you're talking about how
he's hyping himself up and he says he's
so awesome.
Like,
apparently at their wedding he
gave this speech and he said like,
Kim is like a work of art
and the Kardashians are
like this amazing brand and
they're like the future.
He just gave this whole like he is so
into them and her and her family and that
whole amazing brand. That's a compliment.
That's a compliment now. Yeah. Yeah,
he did. And it was saying that right
up there with coachees and yeah,
because of how, but the thing is
though is he, is he completely wrong?
Because they turned her little like z
list status sex tape until like this
million dollar industry to the point
where they're like [inaudible] their
wedding lot. Not saying they're not
successful at it, so their brand is huge.
I'm not saying, I'm not saying
that they're not a huge brand. Oh,
you're saying they compliment.
If you're saying it's a weird
thing to say at a wedding,
but then you're complimenting
a family or an amazing brand.
I can see you guys whoring out all
other aspects of your private lives too,
too will listen.
He,
he himself has said he's not the
greatest speaker. You know what I mean?
Like the way it comes out,
it doesn't always come out the right way,
but for a family who's trying to
be a brand, you know that is a big,
huge compliment.
And I tell you something just got up
and I'm not trying to be a dick here.
Oh God, what do they do?
What exactly do they do?
Everybody always asks that question.
It's a valid, what do they do?
They have a TV show.
They have various fashion lines and
cosmetics and the whole like sort of like,
I know what they have. They have retail
store. I know what they have. They do,
what did they run? They do, they do.
They are the faces of their businesses.
So they are reality stars.
They are reality personalities who have
then transcended the reality genre and
to legitimate million dollar businesses
including clothing and et cetera.
And they, you know, that's in their
spokespeople for various brands. The,
all those pictures of them
come at a Haagen, Dazs dogs.
We would add around Paris
that they came out of Haagen.
Dazs is paying them for that so they get
money. Just to hold an ice cream cone,
which I'll take any fucking day
of the week. Take [inaudible].
You know I can does,
if they were like Bill Barr hundred
thousand dollars you and your wife come
matter Haagen daas holding an ice
cream now you wouldn't do it though.
Cause then cause then I then
you become then, then, then,
then everything you say I, I've, I'm,
I'm still of that. I'm still loved that,
that old school thing
where,
look
this,
this was it.
This was after I've come to this point
as far as what I think selling out,
it's selling out is not
something that the fans decide.
So I shouldn't, I'm not even a fan
of this, but as an observer of them,
I shouldn't say whether they
sold out or not. It's, yeah,
I really think it comes
down to the performer and
basically selling out is when
you don't want to do something,
but you do it anyways because of the
money and then afterwards you feel fucking
horrible to me. If that's what
you feel like at the end of it,
then, then you, you sold
yourself out. You did.
I don't think selling
out, doesn't it? You,
I feel like selling out isn't
even a real thing anymore.
I just feel like that's an antiquated
concept is that I feel like there's no,
the idea of selling out,
I don't,
I don't feel that it
really truly exist anymore.
There's just different platforms for
artists to make money and you know,
your time can come and go very quickly.
So if you can get $100,000 for holding
an ice cream cone and getting your
picture taken, is that really
gonna like keep you up at night?
Like I can't believe I did
that for the money, you know?
No, I'm not saying it's going to,
I'm not saying it's not going to,
I'm going to say with some people
it is and some people it isn't.
Yeah, but you're, you're
very, you're, but you are,
you're very particular about where you
choose to do any kind of advertising and
stuff because you care about stuff
like that. So I understand. Look,
I, I mean I do like
advertising on this podcast.
I'm not against it. I'm not saying
that. I mean love Jesus Christ. To me,
that's how this whole fucking business,
I mean I got to advertise for my shows
and that type of thing, but it's,
it's like anything, it's
like, hey, I like to drink.
Then there's a point where you've drank
too much and you're making an ass of
yourself. There's there, there
are limits to everything. I'm not,
I'm not gonna sit here and be like,
oh,
this is like I'm doing this
grassroots thing. I'm not saying that,
but what I'm saying is like,
just that,
that whole selling out thing, I
think it still exists, but it's,
it's up to the individual.
So I would never say that somebody,
if I see somebody do a commercial, they
sold out, it would have to come from them.
It has to come from them where if they
did it and then afterwards they're like,
oh my, I was in all these great
movies and next thing you know,
I'm standing there doing a cell phone
fucking commercial. And when I saw it,
I just felt like, what did I
do? What did I do to my image?
Because this whole fucking
game, you know, is,
is constantly trying to stay ahead
so they don't fucking pigeonhole you.
And then also not stepping on a fucking
landmine, which is doing a bad movie.
You are putting out a bad special,
there's all these different landmines
that you try not to step on.
But um, I def, I think that
there's, there's all this,
there's definitely ways that you can
sell out, but like the younger me would,
you will, you know, I bonded that whole
Bill Hicks thing of like, you know,
you do do a commercial,
you're off the artistic role call.
And I was hardcore believe in that.
And then by two, you know,
just getting older and it's
just like, no, look, it's, it,
it all comes down that gets your career.
You do
what you want. Look, there's
people out there, I mean,
does commercials for
proactive but so do a lot.
It's like did he didn't want and Katy
Perry doesn't want a lot of them do that
whole,
I had acne and it made me feel really
bad about myself and now I am proactive
and now I'm happy again. And this is the
thing, they can all afford proactive.
So you're basically just going
there to get paid, right.
And you're going to stand there and
the Holden hall closer up to your face.
Now to me, that would make me want to
go jump off a fucking building. Okay.
I felt weird when I first started doing
advertising on this thing, but what I,
what I tried to do is
like, oh, at least like,
I'll try to make these
things fucking funny. But um,
against taking like, you
know, um, advertising, right?
Money, I guess if you really believe
in it, like the shit that I've,
I've read on this stuff, the
stuff that I believe in, right?
I fucking read it. And then if it sounds
fucking stupid of me, Oh, you know,
it just says one. I do. I just say it's
still, what am I going? I'm just saying
it wasn't, you know, look, it was beyond
Sherry's berries and nature's boxes.
There's some shit that fucking
didn't even make the pot God
cast.
There was,
there was one thing that I read when I
wasn't even thinking when we go some,
some fucking banker thing and my buddy,
you know Andrew who puts the whole all
the lists together and everything that I
read, he was in banking. He said, Bill,
these guys that trick and people that
are doing this and they're going to fuck
over you listen to.
So I immediately took it off and I was
there was supposed to do a three week
thing and I had read one of them and
I just told my ad lady said, listen,
just take them off.
That first one's a free one up.
They don't have to pay me
but I don't want to read.
I don't want to read it
cause they know I don't,
I don't have time to fucking
look at all of those things.
So sometimes I will read something they
don't believe in and then if I'm smart
enough, when I catch it, as I'm reading
it, I make fun of it. That's what I do.
I make fun of it and say it's shit.
And then they get mad and they
yell at me or yell at my Ad Lady,
and then we just go, oh, we're
not going to have fucking,
you're not gonna be on the podcast then.
It's cool. Which is funny. So I can,
he can't get fired off your
own podcast. So, um, look,
I'm not saying that like, you know,
I don't want people to think of that.
I'm sitting here saying that I'm this
righteous fucking, I'm not saying
that, but there's definitely,
you know, there's,
I, there's always does always
selling out. There's all,
unless you just completely don't give
a fuck you, you never gave a fuck.
And he does like, look at me and pay me.
I'm going to fucking do it. Then. Then I,
I left about selling out and more about
like survival and more about like,
you know, let me just sort
of hit everything. Well, if
you need the fucking money,
if you need,
look,
if you're sitting there in a house and
they're going to throw you out and then
chitchat comes up, says, Hey,
we want you to wear a thong and go
down a water slide backwards. I mean,
you've got to sit there and be like,
ah, fuck man, I got to do it. I mean,
I can't be out in the fucking
street. Maybe it's not their
first choice, you know,
be paid by Haagen daas again,
but, but he's also, they're
also having a, you know,
a wedding or whatever and
written Versailles and that's
just gotta be paid for.
But listen, so Haagen daas paid
for that. Look, I'm not saying,
I'm not saying that, that if
you do that, you sold out.
But I'm not saying that if you do it,
you didn't.
It all depends on the
person after they did it,
after they fucking did it.
How did they feel if they
thought, fuck, that was great,
that was easy money, blah, blah,
blah, and they continue on,
then I don't think they
sold themselves out.
I really think at this point in my
life, I feel like selling out is, is,
is a personal thing and as much as fans
will accuse of you are a person of it or
whatever,
um,
that it's just speculation because it
really comes down to the person like,
like a lot of musicians now.
I mean because the whole
star making thing went away.
There is no MTV, there is
no videos, there isn't,
there aren't these labels in the CD
stores now. It really is on your own.
It, you know, back in the day
when I was growing up, if, if,
if your music was in a car
and it was in any commercial,
you are a fucking seller
and like that really,
like people would just say
he's a fucking sell out.
He took the corporate buck and all that.
It was a really thing because there was
all these other ways I think then where
you could,
you could still be this big person,
but now be like this pure
artists uncorrupted by the
system that you're trying
to get into. And that's kind of the
whole fucking point of it. Not, it's not.
See now that I disagree
with it, I just, I just,
I disagree with that because what you're
saying is either you're a fucking horse
sucking dick or you're this
lonely bastard rather than that,
then then you can be in a
healthy fucking relationship.
There's plenty of people that look this,
plenty of people that,
that are in this business and they,
they just do their movies.
So they just do their TV show.
This is zillion people that,
and you don't see them going,
like,
I'll tell you and I come home
from work and I want to relax.
I fucking Blahblahblahblahblah this.
Plenty of people that don't do that.
Now I'm not saying that there are any
better than the people who decide like,
yeah, fuck it. I'll take
the money to go to a pro,
actually liked that product or whatever.
Uh, I'm really saying that it's,
it's an individual. It's an
individual thing. All right,
how you want to be perceived,
you know,
how you want to go about this business.
And I think the more that people do it,
the less, um, the, uh, the,
the less it's going to
have like that stigma.
Like you see a lot of these
movie stars that are on doing it.
The commercials now it's
because people stole movies.
So right now basically the
only movies that they make,
it's this shrinking puddle.
The only movies that they make now are
either those hundred zillion dollar
transformer Godzilla things where even
though they're going to be on a pirate
bay,
um,
people still will hopefully want to get
the experience or it's going to be a low
budget thing. The thing that got killed
was the 30, 50, 60, $80 million movie.
Those things are gone.
Not totally be a view.
You get like a Martin Scorsese behind
it. You can get the thing made, but like,
like I don't have the exact numbers.
I was talking to my agent about
this because I'm seeing a lot,
I'm seeing a lot of movie stars all of
a sudden going back to doing stand up.
I'm seeing a lot of them do like, like uh,
commercials and all that type of thing.
It isn't necessarily because they want to.
It's because the business has changed
and is going in the direction of the,
uh, of, of, of the music.
Yeah. So then to that end, and they,
I don't think they can be accused
of selling out either, you know,
because of everything that you
said. I don't think you can, you can
choose anybody of selling out,
but the only person who knows I
feel is the person who did it.
If afterwards when you fucking,
you've walked out of there,
if you felt like you needed a
shower, if you just, you know,
you sit in there and drag fucking
whatever the fuck you're doing,
whatever job it is that you're
doing. Um, and believe me,
I've had those,
I feel like it affects people's
brands are images in that way anymore?
Like I just don't, I don't either. I
don't either. People thought like Kanye,
even getting involved
with Kim Kardashians,
let alone marrying her and singing the
praises of her and her family was going
to like destroy his fan base and
no, no way. It's not happening.
If anything,
it's make it even bigger.
Here's one for you.
This is how much this business has changed
with the perception back in the day.
If you are a movie star, you are a
movie star and you did not do TV.
That was considered a major fuck up.
I mean you could start in the business
too when your commercials and then once
you got to the TV level of something,
it was really hard when you're a TV star,
like they won't even look, oh you though.
People see you on TV, you are this,
you are that, you know, you're a
commercial actor, you're a movie star,
you're a TV star. And then over the
years it started to like, you know,
I mean it was in when it was still,
it was an amazing thing back in the day
when a guy like Bruce Willis went from
moonlighting and then he did die hard
and all of a sudden he was this fucking
movie star. I mean that
was, that was like, that was
still an amazing thing to do.
And now it's like people jump back
and forth, which I think is, um,
is a cool thing. But way back in the day,
it's my who is, who is that? Who is that?
Um, that that actor and actress
we went, um, will going,
went to that party
and turned out she had lived around the
corner I African American actress from
like the thirties or forties
dated that fucker. Yeah.
Now she dated this guy or married this,
this white dude who had a fucking
supper club and he marries her in his
convincing her that she should go
down there as a movie star in Sing,
add his supper club in Hollywood.
That is not going to be filmed.
Nobody's going to see it. And all of
our friends begged her, don't do that.
That's going to kill your
fucking movie career.
If you as a movie star are seen
singing in this supper club.
And I'd love for this guy who
turned out to be not a good guy.
She did it and it actually hurt her movie
career. So back then, you know, like,
like how hardcore those
lines were back then.
I don't think that that exists anymore,
but I have to tell you though,
there are certain people that I don't
want to see doing a fucking snickers
commercial or,
yeah.
How did you feel when you signed Joe
Pesci and the snickers commercial?
Joe Pesci.
Well this is in it for like two seconds,
but those things are well written and
the way it is is what they're actually
saying is you're not yourself. So
there's almost this way that they, it's,
it's a really slick way to
get the celebrity in and
out where they, they don't,
they can just sort of not
have to take a full shower,
just sorta dab the forehead, take
their bag of money and leave. Look,
I'm not saying I would never do
one of those, but as a right now,
like I just feel like, uh, I dunno,
I like telling my jokes and I like
doing the acting gigs that they give me.
And I think that at the end of it all,
you want to have a quality,
you want to have quality.
And I don't,
and I just always,
I always feel like when something that
comes down the pike that is just a money
fucking Gig, there's always that, okay,
I could take this or I could just do a
couple extra weekends a stand up and I
could make up, you know, some of that
money. And then I don't have that.
But I mean, we all got our fucking
shit when we were coming up.
Everybody's got some student films
and shit that you like, that stuff.
I don't count, but I really
feel that, uh, you know,
um, I, but I, at the end of
it, I thought, I, I just,
I just feel it's a personal
thing that like, look, this,
this people who did get sick of
doing the road, and it's like,
I don't want to fucking
go out there anymore.
deal with the check spots.
I don't want to deal with the
drunks up the show. I just, I just,
I don't want to get her another
fucking airplane. Okay. I've had it,
the old me wanting to do that, I did
that and I proved that I could do that.
If you want me to go do a
fucking commercial and take
this fucking money and I'm
a day and a half and it pays my
mortgage for the year, I'll do it.
And I don't think there's a fucking
thing wrong with that. They go, okay,
I don't think there's anything
wrong with it. They go, unless,
unless afterwards you feel like a filthy
fucking whore. So, well
for me, like I, yeah,
and I completely understand
that I think is, for me,
I think I had to sort of come to terms
with the fact that like I am just like a
pop culture.
Like I want to see all that stuff.
So in a way I'm glad that like they're
all out there and their pictures are
being sold to people magazine because
I want to fucking see the wedding.
I want to see like who wins and what
they're wearing and what the castle looked
like and all that kinds of stuff.
How I feel about that show.
That's how I feel about that show.
I find that show depressing.
I find it unbelievable.
Kardashians.
I find it depressing when they're
dealing with depressing shit.
Otherwise it's like kind of mindless,
mindless entertainment I find.
I find the whole fucking thing.
This stuff with Lamar,
I find that fucker thing walking around
in your expensive shoes and you've,
you've flashy bag and this
whole perception of this
life that you're leading.
I, I find all of that. I
don't know why I look at it.
I find it gross and I
just find it depressing.
I'm not saying that somebody shouldn't
live that life and if that's what makes
them happy, it makes him happy. Anytime
I've ever gone to those fucking,
that's all. It's inspiring. It's
aspirational. It's just like, it's like a,
it's a fantasy thing.
Like everyone wants to sort of live in
a world where they're in a movie or in
their magazine like, you know what I
mean? Like, it's, it's part of like,
like I'll tell you, I'll tell you this
as far as like cars, I fucking love cars.
Okay.
But I think it's so much more cooler what
they do on those shows where they take
an old car, you know, like
fast and loud and what they do.
Cause there's an artistry to that, that
stuff. Did they do everything from the,
the deciding of this car,
can we bring this thing back to life?
And then just seeing the old technology
and then see what Erin does to upgrade
it. And then the whole art of Richard
trying to flip the whole thing. I mean,
that to me is way more compelling than
just going down to the lot being I'm
super successful. Uh, so
and so has one of those.
Let me get dad and let me get that in
fucking this color and let me get the
fucking lambos fucking suicide doors.
And then I'm going to call the Paparazzi
and I'm going to go to where the fuck
they're at and I'm going
to have decked out,
head to toe in the sunglass
people paid me to wear it.
And I'm going to step out and then
act like, oh, why are you here?
That shit to me is I find that
gross. Yeah, it's up there.
It's definitely an
element of buttons to it.
There's an art to everything so I'm sure
that there is an art to doing that and
the fact that like
people are what they are,
they have become successful
just by showing themselves
on TV at not as you said,
not doing anything,
quote unquote not being actors
or singers or anything like that.
Just being themselves and they have
built this like sort of empire off of
originally a notorious
thing that happened is I,
is that not impressive? Are you
not entertained? No, no, no.
I'm not saying what they
did was bad or anything.
I just personally when I watch it I just
think it's gross. I think it's gross.
That's somebody's daughter and she made
that fucking video and if what they said
was true that her mother like I don't
know if it leaked out and then her mother
did like the most amazing spin job ever.
I think that's,
to me that's what happened.
This thing. Well, the,
I think that that's the story they tell
because a lot of people, how do you know,
she wasn't like Kim,
get on your knees and suck that deck.
We have to get out of this part of town.
Milton had a sex tape and it didn't,
she didn't sort of go off to become
this thing that, you know her.
Are we talking about talking about
Kim Kardashians she was seeking,
she might've been the ultimate
anymore. No, no, no. That's irrelevant.
She was the original.
Um,
I'm bringing nothing to the table.
I'm just showing up to these events.
She was the original. Yeah, of course. So
what happens is, is just like, you know,
somebody sets the bar for guitar playing,
somebody comes along and has to,
has to,
I'll do that.
She set the bar for empty headed skinny
bitch going to a club who's got more
money than she fucking needs. So then
Kim comes along, it's like, well,
I got to outdo that.
So then metaphorically sucking the dick,
I will literally suck it
and God help.
But did, she was already famous when
she did it. Yeah. That's the difference.
She was already famous for
doing nothing where Kim became,
wasn't famous for doing nothing and then
became famous for doing nothing. We,
I wanted to ask you about one other
thing really quick way I have,
I have advertising to read. Oh, you did.
Let's go into your lovely advertising.
I want to talk to you about
Bruce Willis and Demi Moore.
This is almost a fucking two hour
podcasts. I gotta get Outta here. Oh,
it depends on how long
somebody ride is to work.
MMM.
Well, you know what I want
to hear from you guys, man.
I to hear from a lot of fads. Those little
call one 800, no calm. Let me know. Uh,
what the fuck did the ads go? Did I
finish them all? Um, oh, here it is.
I want to hear what you got. What do you
guys think is selling out? You know, what,
what do you think that
selling out exist anymore?
Like I don't feel like it
really is a thing anymore. Well,
I think also if you grow up just
seeing movie stars doing commercials,
I don't think it's like a big deal. Let's
think about them too. I mean, you know,
these last five years has really changed
because it was funny when you were in
this country, you didn't see movie
stars on billboards and Shit like that.
And then you went to Australia,
you go to Europe,
you see like Leonardo doing the tag hoyer,
fucking things and all this shit.
MMM.
In way back in the day.
Oh my God.
And I hate Cooper doing ads for a hug
and does actually has pictures there.
He might not be coming out of
the thing like Kanye and Kim.
He might not actually be coming
out of the store holders.
And to be honest with you, when I
think about that, when I about that,
it's like what's the,
how much fucking money do you got to
make you fucking the star? Those, those,
the, the three hangover movies,
you could get money for life. Yeah,
but why not make it life?
But why not do that and add to the income?
Because I look at it going, no, we
need it eventually. Like you said,
I want to keep doing movies and acting
as though I get that. I always say,
when this business is finished with me,
they probably have that same,
this is my deal. I look at it like, okay,
so you do all those movies and
you're not getting any more movies.
Then you fucking do them. Fuck it.
I'll do a commercial. Then you do it,
but when you're fucking up there,
I mean the guy was just,
and then he was on another movie that
was up for like best picture and people
want Oscars and,
but the thing is you'll make more money
doing it while you're the big star.
So it doesn't make any sense
to do it after you fall off.
Because then they're like,
hey,
here's five grand taking her leave it and
you're like, fuck, I got to take it. No,
take it now. Bank it.
Ah, I dunno about that.
That's a smarter business decision not
to wait until you're like nobody wants
you anymore. And then you'll hold
an ice cream cone. Like, hi, bye.
Then no one even fucking cares. That's
the other thing I want to, I want to,
you know what?
I would love to talk to a movie star
and ask them how they feel about sitting
there with the ice. Some
looking at the spoon.
You know what's funny? I just, I just
look at it as another acting gig.
I think Kim came out with ice cream.
Kanye was just in there,
but he wasn't holding,
he wasn't photographed holding anything.
And then like her mom has a picture.
Holly and her sister has one.
So I think Kinda was like, all right,
yeah, I'll go in there with you,
but I'm not fucking coming up here with
the ice cream cone because I love you.
Can I shoot this?
Does any of that make you want
to buy Haagen Daz ice cream?
Like it's not like I'm sitting
on the fence going, you know,
I don't know about that. Hug
and does. I love Bradley Cooper.
What is he eating?
Jesus get me three pints of it.
I think it's supposed to be more
subliminal than that. All right,
let's just fucking read these so we can
get out of here. He voice everybody.
Now it's my turn to whore
myself out. I'm, this is,
this is my Haagen and ice cream
right here. Perfect. The segue,
if you take all your
business calls yourself,
it's hard to look professional or get
anything done by helping you expertly
manage all your business calls.
He voice provides you with a
better way to connect your,
to your clients with a toll free number,
professional voice greeting
and a dial by name directory.
He voice transforms any phone
into your business phone. Nia,
please don't be texting when I'm
doing this in my peripheral, my kid,
I already can't read when there's nothing
going on. Uh, when your customers call,
they are automatically sent to you to
wherever you are. Your calls are a,
you can be at home,
you could be at the office is sitting
in your favorite ballpark having a beer.
You're always going to sound
like a fortune 500 company. Yeah.
And what's the drunks? The strength
screaming around you, right? Um, whatever.
There's always a fly in
the ointment anyways,
and you can get all this from only 13 for
under 13 bucks a month. A limited time.
My listeners can try. He voice for free
for 60 days. That's right, 60 days.
But this extended trial will not
last forever. You have to do it now.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and enter the
Promo code bill upon checkout to get
your special offer. Make sure you
hurry, because this offer will end soon.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com Promo
Code Bill B I. L. L. That's easy.
voice.com Promo Code Bill. And
lastly, but not leastly legal zoom.
Everybody.
America was built by inventors
and dreamers and murderers.
Maniacs that thought their race
was better than the others.
People like Thomas Edison and Henry Ford
laid the foundation for our country.
Um, these days it's the adventures and
entrepreneurs all around us like you that
keep our country running by fueling the
job market and the economy. This month,
legal zoom celebrates innovations
by helping you launch your dream.
Apply for a patent to secure
your invention. I love this
thing. All right, people,
people invented stuff. Always get
taken advantage of. All right,
pat and your thing that whatever you're
inventing and when you go to those
corporate, you know what's, um,
do not give up on a ship and you're
probably going to have to or they'll just
steal it from you. Anyways.
Register your trademark to promote,
protect your products and services.
Incorporate or form an LLC
in launch your business best.
Seeing who I guess is settled
out of court with them, right.
Visit Legal zoom.com and use the
discount code bur bur they'll provide the
professional attention you need and
help take care of all the details.
They've helped over a million
businesses get started, right,
and they received an a plus from
the better business bureau bureau.
Celebrate innovations with legal zoom
today and a special offer price or
trademark copyright or provisional patent
application by using the discount code
[inaudible] at checkout.
Legal Zoom provides legal help through
independent attorneys and self help,
but they are not a law firm.
legalzoom.com discount code burr. Hey Nia.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Come in here for
you know what's funny about this?
I was just thinking as I was reading
that was that later on in my career,
right?
Yeah.
When it's all fucking set had done and
they are done with me and I'm doing a sag
nut bar commercial, people will
take the audio from this. Yeah,
but I never said that it was, I never,
I, I said it was an individual thing.
I will tell you this and I could
tell you without a fucking doubt.
As far as I feel that if I ever did
one of those that I would, I would,
I don't know how I would be able,
I mean I guess you change every
four or five years, you know?
I guess as you become an older man and
he just don't want to fucking go out
there or anything, like how you change
your physicality. When you say older man,
you're such an actor at heart.
You just kind of like bent over and may
just off physically and old man come an
older man. Yeah. He just, he like, you
know what you, when I eat candy bars,
I like this candy bar.
I don't give a fuck if you want to pay
for my prostate exam this month. Go ahead.
Do it. Now the fear is that, yeah,
the business will be done with you and
you're not gonna have anywhere to turn. So
make your money and hopefully, you know,
you pay your fucking house,
you buy a house you can afford
and you pay the fucking thing off.
And then the next thing you do is you
go out, you buy rental properties,
so then you don't fuck those people over.
But they help pay that thing off.
And then in the end of your life,
if you got a problem,
you can sell one of those fucking units.
That's what I want to do.
As opposed to go on and sit
there and look with an amaze.
Look on my face as the microwave.
Microwave popcorn is popping. Okay.
But this is the thing,
actually,
I shouldn't even say that because there's
so many commercials that I think is so
funny and great and I
think the performances of
commercials that are like, oh,
they're way better than that.
Yeah, they're way better
than than they used to be.
But I guess the nightmare
is you know what it is.
You just don't want to be in something
that sucks. It's fucking cheesy. Maybe.
Maybe that's what it is with
every movie or TV. So you do,
you don't really know as an answer unless
you are like the director or producer,
not just in name, but a real producer on
it. You have no idea how it's gonna go.
So you will go up, but you get
the scripts. Awesome. Yeah.
You think this is going to be, this is
a funny script, is a great director,
writer bubble,
and it comes out and it's tracked.
You're telling me that that same,
you think that's,
do you think that same thing happens
when you get the copy for the Zag nut bar
commercial? No, but at least you know what
she say on paper. This looks good. Oh,
but you know,
you know exactly what you're getting into.
You know exactly the purpose
for this thing. You don't,
you don't know exactly what
you get your son is that,
I can't believe you said not yourself.
Oh, you're so old. Sometimes.
He snippers Fifth Avenue,
Fifth Avenue,
payday, payday, marathon bar commercials
prepare their think. But, but anyway,
yeah,
no more what you're getting into because
you have no power on how they're going
to edit it. You don't know who's
fucking direct in the goddamn thing.
You don't know if they, if he
the editor as opposed to, wow,
this is really something that
I was really believed in.
And it's unfortunate that it didn't,
you know,
you didn't get to see what we really
speaking to that how many buddies,
how many people's careers were ruined
by that one. Batman movie was one,
one of the one where the went chick
and when the girl went, oh no,
she played poison. Oh Shit. Oh, Scarface.
Michelle Pfeiffer. And then the guy,
the guy doing the fucking,
the guy doing the TV show with ll cool J.
Okay.
Chris, uh, Chris Christiansen,
he played Robin. He played Robin.
That's career wasn't ruined. He's on
that. He took a major fucking hit.
He didn't write that God,
their movie wasn't his fault.
He was playing the boy wonder whole CSI
and he's doing all right. I know, but he,
he in there. Yeah, but he was on the
fucking ropes because of that movie.
Okay.
Yeah. Well, you know
what I didn't want my point
is I'm just saying, all right,
I'm not trying to do a two hour podcast
is like seeing a to 200 point envy again
later on so we can talk
about what that word mean.
Addendum. That's like an addition Scout
Willis. What was weekend too? It's,
this has been over two hours. I don't
think my listeners give a fuck about what,
what happened was Scout Willis.
Well she's uh,
she went parading around New York a
topless because she was in protest of
Instagram cutting out her
account because you know,
she was wearing a sheer top
in his shoulder nipples.
And that's been a thing where
people's nipples or whatever,
haven't been on Instagram.
Like they shut down Rihanna as account
because she posted some pictures from a
magazine. She like a French
magazine shoot. She did. And
then this editor at Vogue,
uh,
named Grace Cottington just put a picture,
like a stick figure thing with little
nipples on it and they shut down our her
account.
They gave her account back because it
was ridiculous cause of the cartoon
because this whole thing now
where Instagram is like, you know,
cutting people off or
excessive nudity and shit.
So Scout Willis and protest quote unquote
when walking around topless in New
York City and had our picture taken
and stuff because she was like,
I just got my breasts reduced. I
felt good about myself. And you know,
Instagram is shaming people and I think
that is the most ridiculous non cause
ever. Like really scout will
as the daughter of delight,
famous movie stars,
you're really being oppressed by Instagram
because they want to shut down the
fucking nipples.
It was the most insane,
ridiculous thing I had ever seen it
in my mind. Think about their uh,
their, no, no nipple policy. I mean,
I mean I don't, I don't give a
fuck. Yeah, no nudity. Sure. Fine.
I feel like I still see plenty of booty
shots on it. Yeah. That's like youtube.
It's like,
you know,
there's a certain level of whoredom
that you can go to and then they stopped
because they're trying to
protect their image. Yeah. Exit.
I tried to come a porno hub.
Exactly.
And they've got all kinds
of young kids on it,
so they're trying to
be mindful of that too.
They don't want it to be
what's funny about like,
don't use Instagram heads in a zillion
places on the fucking Internet.
That's just like, you know, I've talk,
I wouldn't talk like this and church
am I let him an old during somebody's
speech. But you know, right. You got
to respect. It's Instagram. That's it.
That's their church. And yeah, and
that's the thing. I don't, I don't,
the thing is though,
she's really trying to make
it about censorship and
you're shaming women and men
can go,
right.
It's like you are not shamed or
being like oppressed in any way.
Daughter of famous, yet guys
are being oppressed. Oh God.
Guys are being oppressed God. Cause you
get to look at Man tits all the time,
man. And I can't see,
you know, that's all.
That's all we're thinking about as mantids
male, male, male, pex. I'm sure you're,
and I'm sure you're really like scared
that all the people googling your, your,
your pecs, right? You live sort of
in that fear of going to the beach.
I looked like a piece of chalk that was,
somebody threw some cinnamon at flex.
Some cinema really annoyed me that
Scout Willis has the to act like she was
somehow being oppressed in any way
because Instagram bands are account names.
Scout.
What do you think they're going to fuck
it do their parents were movie stars.
What do you think they're going to do?
You know,
even Rihanna is like whatever moving
on and just as her Twitter account now,
and she had an a and the thing
is she wasn't even doing it.
Like I'm doing it for Rihanna.
In fact, she had split.
I'm not gonna try to act like
all black people know each other.
But is there any way you can get in touch
with her and tell her to stop drawing
on herself? Rhea, Rhea,
her tattoo. Oh my God. Yes.
No I don't. I don't know where yet. I
saw no, I would not be with her. Uh,
with their air force tattoo under a tip
to something that's not an iron maiden
has power slave album cover that she has
that little uh, what she wants with
her body. And what's your little,
some on the side, what's your problem
with Rihanna? Having a bunch of tattoos.
She's got a beautiful body. She
has a great canvas for it. Yeah.
No and so he started scribbling
all over it. Oh, you're like anti,
you're not completely anti tattoo, but
you're kind of our anti tattoo. Oh,
you know what I don't like,
I don't like when somebody tries to
write something fucking deep on their rib
cage or their shoulder blade like hey,
the next time the butterfly flaps its
wings. You're talking about Megan Fox?
No I'm not.
Oh cause she had something
that butterflies will latch
the gilded butterfly or
something about Jesus when the fire dances
with the water on the butterfly wings
that drunk Jim Morrison Horse Shit,
you got on the back of your leg.
I don't give a fuck. Like, like,
like just advertising that you,
you understand life or some shit.
Like I'm supposed to be like, wow,
that person is deep. Yeah.
You know, tattoo artists
don't like doing those things.
They float. Yeah. Cause
they feel like they say,
they feel like they're on punishment.
Like they're writing.
Like I will not talk in class because
they're just sitting there writing.
There's nothing creative about
it. Well then that's, let's see.
That's how I feel about Scout
Willis. It was, I was very, my role,
my eyes rolled in the back of my head.
I was having a seizure.
That's how hard we were at the two
hour mark. We are at the two hour mark.
I'm going to end this bitch fest.
Thanks for having me on the
podcast on my birthday. No worries.
It's already three 15 now.
Half over notice was half over at noon,
but you stay up until three Oh, so
then you find, right? Yeah, exactly.
That's what you're trying to say. Oh,
artists. Artists can't do math. All right,
I'll talk to you guys next
week. Hey, watch the kings
and ranges. Go Fuck Yourself.